(yelling)
- Probably do a (yelling)
montage one day.
- No, no, no.
- But like a fast cut, just like.
(yelling)
- At the beginning of every
fucking Trash Taste podcast.
Just one of us going.
(yelling)
- I'm waiting for the day that
someone just like samples,
all of our audio and just makes
like a low-fi beat out of it.
- Do it.
(laughing)
(mellow music playing)
- Hello and welcome to Trash Taste.
The anime podcast, where
we talk about Japan, food
shitting and occasionally anime.
I am your host for today, Gigguk.
And with me, are the boys.
- That's our new tagline.
- As always.
- Isn't it?
(laughs)
I was just like, well, what is a tagline
that could go well with Trash Taste?
- I mean,
that sounds about right.
(Gigguk laughing)
- Like that's probably
the most accurate.
(Gigguk laughing)
- The anime podcast.
- Anime podcast where it's 5% anime,
- [Gigguk] Exactly.
- 95% everything else.
- But how are you guys doing?
- Good.
How are you boys doing?
- Good. Good.
- Doing all right.
- Since last week
we spoke about Claymore
and I was like fuck it.
I'll read Claymore.
And it was really good.
- You literally just finished it like
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Two minutes before we started recording.
- But to be fair,
(laughing)
If you haven't read Claymore
and are thinking about it.
Don't worry about it.
You don't need to know anything.
Manga's good until the halfway
and then it kind of just goes a bit shit.
- Yeah, second half's
definitely underwhelming.
- The *star's amazing.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I feel like a lot of
anime or manga do this.
Where they build up like
this fucking amazing world
that I think is too big of a scope.
And then they just *let like fuck,
we need to finish this.
- Yeah.
Like within like 200 chapters.
- Mm.
- How do we do that?
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Well
I think for a lot of the times,
at least with like Shonen Jump
cause *claim was from Shonen Jump.
A lot of the times the authors
don't really have a choice
as to how long it goes for.
- Right.
- I feel like
Shonen Jump goes through the same problem.
As you know, a lot of American
TV shows where, you know
you have some like rare,
like something like
Breaking Bad for example,
it's like a rarity where
a show just gets better,
it hits its peak and then it
stops, you know what I mean?
But the problem which
- Then better call Saul
comes along.
(laughing)
- But that's more like a spinoff.
- I think Better Call Saul's
better than Breaking Bad.
- Oh. Okay. You're one of those.
- I think it's really fucking good.
(mumbles)
- No. You're one of those.
- You're one of those.
- I think it's really
fucking good. I don't know.
- I haven't seen either
one so I can't say.
- Okay. Yeah, go on.
But yeah, the problem with a lot of it,
like Shonen Jump Manga,
is that the most of the time
they either go on for too
short or they get dragged out.
You either you're either like
a Bleach or you are something
that gets canceled early,
like most other Shonen Jump shows.
- Yeah. That's the thing is right.
Is that like with Shonen Jump,
they have every month they have rankings.
- Right.
- And if you have even just
a slight dip in popularity,
then they're kind of just
like well time to wrap it up,
boy oh.
*And the author's like well,
I, I just, I just got started.
It's like, it doesn't matter.
You got to wrap it up.
- I-
- I wonder if that's what
happened, but to be fair,
when I was reading this it's 150 chapters.
Around like the 80th
is, I was like, ah, yeah
this isn't going to end like great.
- Oh*!
- It ended.
which is better than most.
- I mean, you know, yeah.
It's better than like
what happened to like Yuyu Hakusho right?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like the last doctor's got
completely fucking gutted.
(laughing)
- I mean, you can tell
when an, when an author
just like has to wrap things up
in five chapters or something.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just like-
- Yeah, yeah. True, true.
Some, some, some stuff that
they've been building up
for like a hundred to 200
chapters just gets wrapped up
in 10 chapters and you're
like, what the fuck was this?
- It's like, cool.
- And then there's like
the opposite of that
with what's the Manga
cover Hunter Hunter called?
- Togashi.
- Togashi. Yeah, he introduces
like the dark continent
when he can't make one chapter.
And he's like, how about I
just expand the world tenfold.
- I tweeted out about it the
other day, but I found out
the other day that in
the span that it took
Togashi to release chap-
Volume 32 to 33, Assassination
Classroom started and ended.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
So if you don't know, Hunter
Hunter has been on hiatus.
Not hiatus. Basically, we had a chapter
like once every two years.
- No, it's definitely a hiatus.
- Yeah, yeah. We got a check
once or two years.
- H X H is short for hiatus
and hiatus.
(laughing)
- What counts as a hiatus nowadays?
Is, is it like a Hunter Hunter hiatus
or Berserk Mura* hiatus.
You know what I mean?
- I mean kind of the same thing.
- I mean it's just like,
maybe it's just a very
slow release schedule,
you know what I mean?
- True, true, true.
- But have you seen some of
Hunter Hunter's latest chapters?
Have you seen some of the
dark continent chapters?
I've read.
I've seen like some of the later chapters
and some of them are just
literally there are pages
that it's just all texts.
`There's like one character
and it's literally
- I actually saw it on Twitter, right?
Yeah. It's just a full page of text.
And at this one, I'm just like Togashi,
if you want to write a light novel
just write a light novel.
- This Manga * is just
somehow like writing a book
without realizing, I don't
know how you do that.
- I mean, he's kind of releasing volumes
on the schedule of like
light novel volumes.
- Exactly. It's like, why, why
why are we pretending that
this is a Manga anymore?
- And like the drawings?
Oh my God. Like-
- Yeah.
Just hire
- I mean. It's like-
- Hire someone on deviant art man.
Just do it already like.
(laughing)
What's going on?
- Well, wait.
What I want to know is like
cause I don't think Togashi
uses assistance.
- Maybe. Probably not.
Would spend a lot.
- Probably not
Because if not you'd think-
- This is all assumptions,
I think
- You'd think that he'd get
assistance to draw, right?
- [Meilyne] Wife.
- His wife?
- Oh, well yeah. His wife
is the author of Sailor.
Shit. So I guess.
- Almost dissed on his wife.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- We dissed one of the greatest
* Manga authors of all time.
(laughing)
All right, listen. Hunter Hunter.
If you haven't read or
seen it, just do it.
It's amazing.
But be prepared for I guess
- I just say
- To never be felt complete.
- So here's the thing.
- I haven't read Hunter Hunter at all,
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- But I have
all of the volumes up until this point.
- Honestly, watch the anime.
The anime is so fucking good.
- Yeah. No-
- The anime's great.
It's one of the few anime
that I think is better than the manga.
- Yeah.
- Really?
- And that's because-
- The 2011 version?
- Yeah The 2011 version.
- Yeah.
- Because some of the later like arcs,
especially the Chimera Ant arc
Togashi's arc is really up and down.
- Right.
Because of, you know his
health complications.
That was going through but like
the anime is just consistent throughout.
- Okay, okay.
- So then when he doesn't
know, I would recommend him
because I'd recommend-
- Because I know so much about
the series, like of like
characters and like *yeah.
(mumbles) you know.
- I know so many references
but I've actually sat down a read a lot.
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- I think I know enough
about Naruto to like,
to like lie
- Yeah.
my way through a conversation and be like,
(laughs) oh yeah, the leaf village? Crazy.
- I could probably lie my way
through a Fullmetal Alchemist
conversation.
- Yeah *(laughing)
- I have done many times.
- Ah , man. That's just so sad bro.
- I mean let's be real!
Like, I feel we've all done that
where like everyone around you is talking
about an anime and you kind
of just like, huh yeah. That.
That thing.
- For like five years, I was an anime fan
who hadn't watched *Stephen galleon.
People would be like, dude, it's Epic.
I'm like, yeah dude. Get in the robot.*
(laughing)
Yeah, my dad hates me.
- Yeah, dude. Love that.
Love the part where the mechs* fight.
(laughing)
That's just crazy.
Just do that
- I admittedly did that a
little bit with, with Bleach.
- It's when you're insecure, right?
- Yeah. I did that for a while with Bleach
because I didn't, I
dropped it at the Eisenach.
So anything after that,
I had no fucking idea,
but people around me kept
reading it and they were like,
yeah! You know, the whole
like wicked *mundo stuff.
I was like, yeah,
that thing. Yeah.
- Whack a mundo?*
That thing. Totally. *munjo.
- To be fair.
To be fair, which is one of,
one of those anime or manga that you could
you could feasibly lie your
way out of it and make it seem
like you've seen it without having seen it
after you've watched like
a further first few arcs,
then you kinda just kinda just
you kinda can just
bullshit your way through.
- I too also want
to see more bang kae*
- I feel like this thing
One Piece, right?
Cause One Piece is so long.
It's like the Simpsons, right?
Where everything that could ever happen
has probably happened.
(laughing)
So you could be like,
dude, my favorite episode
is where like Homer Simpson
becomes a crack addict.
That's probably an episode
on the Simpsons, right?
- I mean You can probably do
that with One Piece right now
'cause you're the only
one who hasn't seen it.
So you can just randomly be like, yeah
I love that episode with
*Loofy and Chopper make out.
- I love the ep-
I love the part where the pirates
find another band of pirates
that are bad initially
and then turn and are a
part of some military.
And then they're like,
do let's just be good.
Let's help Loofy out.
- Oh yeah. The water seminar.
(laughing)
- Is that like a thing?
(mumbles)
- That probably happened.
- Probably. Something.
- That was vague enough that
- If I keep it vague
that could be about four
different arcs of One Piece.
- Yes. I know enough base
information about One Piece.
I still haven't read it yet.
Again, I downloaded some episodes,
some chapters on my phone
but maybe, maybe one day.
- So you're downloading a
lot of chapters now. I see.
No, I have like
I have like 10 volumes
downloaded, which isn't much.
- How far into it?
- I don't fucking know.
- Well, because we're approaching what?
Volume a hundred of One Piece.
- We were approaching chapter a thousand,
I think all the way which is
going to be a landmark and yeah
- Yeah. Whoa.
(laughing)
- A thousand chapters.
That's-
- Can you imagine?
Fucking a thousand. Every week.
A thousand chapters.
- I cannot fucking imagine.
- That's a thousand
weeks at least minimum.
- Because what I-
- Has he married the author?
- I think so.
I think so.
- It's kind of interesting.
because, yeah.
- Meyner* be the fact checker.
- It's kind of interesting
actually because Oda Eiichiro
Oda Eiichiro
I feel like you can't be
married and make One Piece.
Like it's, it's pick one.
- Well, it's so interesting
because like I feel not a whole-
- He is married.
- He is married. Okay,
because like not a whole
lot about Oda is even known.
Because he's so rarely what
makes any like TV appearances
or like interview appearances.
Cause it's too busy fucking
writing a chapter a week, right.
- He's not just doing that.
Cause Oda out of every
author is way more involved
in the anime production as well.
- [*] Right, right.
Because normally-
- he helps produce, right?
Yeah, yeah. Normally a
lot of Amie productions
people were just like,
okay, there's the author.
And then the author just get sidelined
and they just continue doing that stuff.
And maybe they'll watch
the anime, you know?
But you know, Oda's been involved
in a lot of the anime
production, which I did...
Where does he find the time to do this?
I don't know.
Ah, like as a sh-
this man is like
a time management machine.
- As a Shonen Jump author,
I don't know how you can have a life.
Like most authors don't have a life.
outside of their magazine.
I mean, most of them
have health complications
because of how much they work.
- Not to mentioned that like I swear
with every new chapter
odors, art is just evolving.
Like it's getting more, like some
of the recent chapters
are so fucking detailed
- Yeah.
- Where it's like,
how do you draw this in a week?
- Yeah. Exactly. Why
people like to piss on
One Piece character designs
because oh it looks good cartoonish.
Looks childish.
- They do look fucking weird.
- They do look weird.
- Yeah, but at least it's like so distinct
to the point where you can look
at a character and be like,
oh yeah that's a One Piece character.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Yeah. True.
You can say about Simpsons,
but you know what I mean like.
- Well, yeah!
- Or Family Guy character.
- Yeah, exactly.
Maybe.
- But I would argue
that that's better than
a fucking generic Goss looking
character that could fit
into any like, you know,
show of that caliber, right?
- I mean it's way-
Any one of Oda's character
designs is way more memorable
here's generic Isokai*
protagonist number 75
- That's true.
that looks like Kerato, just re-skinned*,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's, that's what I think.
I think that's my biggest
problem with a lot
of light novel adaptations
is that you can tell lighten
of adaptations nowadays
by just by just the character design.
- How they look
- And just the art style as well.
(laughing)
- Yeah. Because the character
designs haven't changed
from like 10 years ago.
- Yeah, I know, right?
- It's like good-looking
boy with average proportions
with a spiky hair,
color it in.
A weird color? There you go.
- Exactly.
- Like even a lot of
like the girls as well.
Cause I think one-
- Here's pink haired
character.
- Like, like one of my favorites
One of my favorite female
characters to come out
of recent times is *my Sacra d Jima
from Bonnie Gail senpai.*
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And like, I really liked all
of the cast there and all of
the characters, but my God
they have such forgettable
character designs.
- [*] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
Compared to some of, some of
the characters times from say
like *Mona Guthrie or something
like that, which you know
it gets compared to, compared a lot to
and I see the same charm,
but in terms of the memorability
of the character designs,
it's just *bunny Girl's senpai just
looks like the most generic.
- Well, I mean,
that's why they had to-
- well to be honest,
- That's actually of the
reasons I just didn't watch it.
- That's why they had to put
her in a bunny costume, right?
- [Gigguk] Exactly
(laughing)
- To like differentiate between
all the other characters.
- Exactly.
- Because there's a
lot of anime characters
just like silhouette or eyes, right?
You can just know.
- Right. And like, you
know, I would argue again
like that's one of the strong
suits about one piece, right?
Is that like, because the character
look so fucking wacky.
- Yeah.
- You can immediately tell
that's a One Piece character.
- Yeah.
- And it's the way I
describe Oda is it's some,
it's like you're reading
a story with, from someone
who has the imagination of a ten-year-old
but the writing skills
of like Joe R R Martin
or something like that,
- Yeah.
you know what I mean?
It's so weird because you see a character
like this cross-dressing
ballerina, for example.
And you're like,
what is this wacky character?
- Number three?*
- Yeah, yeah.
Mr. Two*
- Mr Two*
I mean Mr. Two.
- So yeah, Mr. Two. Mr Two.*
- What the fuck?
(laughing)
- Yeah, I always get the numbers mixed up.
- Mr. Two* bond clay summer
- Mr. Green eggs and ham.
(mumbles)
He's great. He's great.
(laughing)
I love that guy.
- But yeah, you see his character design
for the first time and
you're just like this.
I'm never going to give
a about this character
and then he ends up in later arcs
bringing you to tears sometimes.
And just like, how did this happen?
How, how does he make,
how did Oda make me care
about this person right now
that you can see on screen?
Anyone who hasn't watched One
Piece is probably looking at
this being like what the fuck?
- Who is this clown?
- Who is this literal clown?
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
- That's your mon-
your weekly jack off to One Piece
segment of the podcast.
- Yeah.
- As we're going to do
every week now for example.
- We are we going to do
every week until you-
- Until you start reading it.
- If I read it, well this will become
a fucking One Piece podcast.
- No, no, no. No it won't.
No it won't. But it might
become more of a Manga podcast.
(laughing)
- My, my I'll spend like
20 hours reading a Manga.
My review will be like,
yeah, it's all right.
- So wait, so what would you
give out of 10, Claymore?
- Six.
- Six?
- See I don't want to read
anyone else's reviews of Manga.
At all.
(laughing)
I don't want to know.
Cause I feel like right
now, because I don't-
- All right, I'm gonna head out. (laughs)
I don't touch anything with reviews.
in terms of Manga.
I don't know what the popular opinion is.
I don't know if I should go to a thing.
I think it's good or bad.
I just see something
I'm like, I'll read that
and make up my own choice.
Kind of like it there in my own bubble
of like,
- That's fair enough.
I don't give a shit
what anyone else thinks.
- It's weird. Right? Because
I feel like manga readers
just exist in their own bubbles, right?
Cause when we talk about
the anime community
most people refer to it as like
the Anime and Manga community.
It's we kind of, we're kind of
we're kind of assumed
that we're just synonymous
with each other, right?
But then there are times
when I just kind of realized
that I have no idea what's going on
in the Manga world sometimes.
Like there's this recent
airing Anime right now
called a Horimia. That-
- The fuck is that?
- So good.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Ah, so good.
Exactly Mayline* just
like Evangelic
- [Mayeline] Favorite Manga
The Manga's favorite Manga
according to Mayeline.
- The Manga is
fucking awesome.
When the anime is getting adapted.
There was like so many
Manga readers that would just
- They come out.
- They just come out, just
come out and say, Oh my God,
this is my favorite Manga.
I fucking love this Mongo.
And here I'm thinking
where where's is this rock
that you're all living on?
What is this rock?
- This is the thing, right?
I say six out of 10
but I'm sure that they're like me.
They're like, I forget about it.
But when the animation out announced
I'm like, yo, yo,
(laughing)
that's my fucking favorite.
I love that one.
I read that ages ago.
I loved that.
- No, because the thing is,
I had never heard of Horimia.
Before the anime got adopted
this winter season, right?
- [*] Right.
And I was just like, it
must be a pretty, like
it must have like a cult
following or something.
So search it up and-
- Oh it has a cult following
all right.
(laughs)
And it is following it is the 13th
most popular Manga of all
time on my anime list.
And I'm just like, how have I never
how have I never heard this name before?
Or how's no one discussed
this in my presence before?
I thought.
- Reading bad.
- Well, that's the thing.
That's what I find so interesting about
the Manga wall is that even if
it's like universally praised
and credited as being
this most amazing piece
of work right in the Mongo wall,
it's just really surprising how few people
in the Anime community
actually know about it.
Like, I guaran-fucking-tee.
Not many people know
about like Oyasumi Punpun.
Even though I think it's like the second
or third highest rated Mongo on Val*.
- I feel like I feel like, I
dunno some like sane in Manga.
You, you have like the sane* in big four.
I think you have like, Binland* saga
- Always the fucking big numbers.
(laughing)
It is cause it's not
quite the medium for it.
(laughing)
- Why, why why always the big one?
- The small four!
- What happened to the top?
(laughing)
That, that describes things pretty well.
- We should rename it.
(mumbles) like the giga four or something.
- Gigic four.
- It might be, might be three.
I can't remember cause it's it's all.
- Which ones are you referring to?
- You know the crowd that
always talk about Vinland Saga.
It's either Vinland Saga,
Berserk or a fucking
- Kamuy?
Fuck. Vagabond.
- Oh Vagabond. Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think there's one more.
That is in that genre that everyone keeps.
- Maybe Golden Kamuy?
- No, that's not Golden Kamuy,
but maybe it's just a big three.
Maybe, maybe I'm just imagining things.
But like, I feel like a lot
of sane in Manga gets talked
about as like these masterpieces,
you know what I mean?
But some like slice of
life, romance, manga
like Horimia that is
apparently very popular.
Just don't get talked about
in the same sphere and-
- Well, I would argue
that like even the big
the big three scene, and I
guess we've coined it now
like *Bailey had told us about light.
It upsets me how few people
know about like Vagabond.
- Really?
- Yeah. I feel like a lot of
people know about Vagabond.
- I know about Vagabond.
- Okay.
(laughing)
(mumbling)
- Damn it.
- I know it is a title that exists.
I know absolutely nothing about it.
So vagabond essentially is
a it's a samurai Mongo*.
- Yeah.
- But I would, but it's done by the author
who did Slam Dunk.
- Oh, that sounds cool.
- Yeah.
So you know where somehow
not only managed to make one
of the greatest sports Manga ever made
but also one of the greatest
samurai Manger ever made.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Mm.
And it's fucking amazing.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- How many chapters is it?
- Still going?
(sighs)
- It's still ongoing but it's-
- It's on hiatus.
- I don't know what it is about this.
You know, the, the brutal scene in Mongo
where they get up to
like 200 or 300 chapters
and the author's like
aight, I'm a head out.
- I'll take a break.
(laughing)
I think at least the Manga I've read.
It feels like they build up
like a really cool world.
And again, they just like,
it either gets too big
and they're just like, well
I've gotta reign this in.
It just gets way too big
and it ends with like so many
fucking things not explored.
- Yeah, cause cause like
Going back to Hunter Hunter.
Like it got up to a point
where I'm just like, this is a
this is a comfortable place to end it.
You know what I mean?
This is a comfortable
place to like try it.
Yeah, no, it definitely
could have ended it.
And then she introduces the dark continent
which without spoiling the exact
details of it is
- Fuck outta here. No one's
ever gonna see the end of it.
- You have this, you have this world
that's a gushy buildup in Hunter Hunter.
And it was like, how, how long was
like the run, whatever, the 148 episodes.
- Yeah, 148 episodes, right?
- Jesus.
Right. And it ended to a point where you
explored everything you needed
to explore about the world.
And he went on hiatus and
everyone was just like,
Oh you know, HunterxHunter
must be coming to an end.
- Right.
And then he comes back and
he's just like, J K by the way
this is just one fifth of the world.
- That's...
(laughing)
I hate it when they do
that, man, like don't
don't come here and
pull it out of your ass.
It's like a fucking like
parody iPhone presentation.
It's like, but wait, there's more
It's like, wait, but no stop, stop.
They shouldn't be as cool as the idea is
of like expanding the world.
It's honestly one of the things
That makes me roll my eyes, emotion.
I've been reading manga
lately is when that like
but there's another continent or planet.
And I'm like, Oh, for fuck's sake
There is not going to be
another planet that is
going to be satisfied.
- Yeah.
- That's, that's exactly how
I felt when like, you know
in like dragon ball, when
they started expanding
on like multi-verse and
shit I was like, bro
I thought like I thought
like blowing up planets
and like taking over the
universe was hard enough.
And now it's like, well, you know
there's like seven more
universes out there
that we can explore as well.
It gets my chub like softer
than hearing multi-verse
or like expanding the
universe out of like.
- I think the one thing I
hate the most is how like
I don't mind them like
introducing that kind of thing.
If they Actually follow through with it.
- Yeah, yeah. But the problem
is they'll just drop it.
In like a chapter there'll
be like, Oh, by the way
There's other worlds.
(laughing)
And it's like no there wasn't.
There was never, you never made this mango
with other worlds in mind.
You liar, you're adding this now.
(laughing)
- Yeah, that is true.
- Cause like okay back.
Sorry to bring it up again.
For like the ninth time.
But like what I was reading Claymore
they just casually
mentioned that like there's
two worlds having a
wall and then it's like
Never brought up again
and then it just ends.
And we never hear anything
about the other world.
That's apparently having a war.
It's like, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa.
So everyone gets to go alone happy.
But the whole reason
why this world exist is
because there was a war and
this is like a testing.*
It's really bullshit.
Like I don't, I don't
like it when they do this.
Especially when the
Manga is like, you know
it's been going on for a long time.
- Right.
and it already feels like
it's stretching thin.
And then they're like nother world, baby.
It's like, no, no,
no, no, no.
- True, true, true.
- Because I think you said
if they build it up fine
but when they just drop it, I hate it.
- Yeah.
- No, you sometimes see
these plot points in Manga.
It's just like dropped.
And for some reason you just never
never hear about it again,
like aside from other worlds
the biggest example I can
think of is the Gantz Manga.
- Oh my God.
I love that one.
But I was so dumb.
- Yeah. Well I just like
remember when there were vampires in it
and that was a big plot point,
- Oh yeah, there was
then they just disappeared.
like the vampire gang.
- Yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- Just never heard about it again.
- There's a lot of stuff in Gantz.
So if you haven't read
Gantz, I guess you could.
It's very long.
It's written...
The artwork is fucking amazing.
We spoke about it before,
but yeah, randomly
halfway through, they introduced vampires
into a world that never had vampires
and then they just never come up again.
(laughing)
- Not going to lie.
Like I barely remember
any of it because I think
at that point I kind of
just like erase the front.
I was like, this is so dumb.
I don't even want to
like put it's a memory.
- I just kind of, I
always offhand remember
you know, sometimes you
just get flashbacks.
- You wake up at night sweating.
- Oh God. There was vampires!
- You wake up.
- You wake up and you just
like whatever happened
to those vampires?
(laughing)
where did they disappear to?
They were built up as like
the big fucking villains
or something.
- Yeah, yeah.
And then they just, they
just went nowhere with it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I guess that's the problem
of when you're like
serializing a Mongo every week.
I wonder how much of it like
is actually planned before
and how much it just feels
like it's falling apart.
Which is why the The more manga I read,
the more I respect to something
like one piece, which can
keep coherency this long.
You know what I mean?
And, and it just continually
getting more and more epic, right?
- And just continually
getting better and better.
But I mean like that's also
why I really value when
a Manga just has a good
ending, not even a Mongo
but just any media in
anime, Mongo or light novels
that just has an ending that
people are satisfied with.
- I don't ask for much
but I do ask for a
satisfactory ending to a story.
- I'm just the more
I've been reading Manga.
My pet peeve is like where
it just starts to fall apart
like in the last 40 50
chapters that's been really
that's been happening a lot
- Nothing ruins I feel like
an experience of going through
this entire long journey with
these characters that you fall
in love within this
world that is interesting
to come to limp dick ending.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
Like there are like, I, I swear to God
I can count the amount of
like satisfying endings
on like my hands in, in
that I've read in Mongo.
- [*] Right.
because there is like most of the manga
that I love are still ongoing,
like classics, like Bezerk,
Vagabonds, Vinland Saga, for example.
And then there are other
things like Slam Dunk.
Where you just feel, you know,
it just kind of, kind of just ended.
you know what I mean?
It had its, you know what, come on.
You can't say that that
final chapter of slam Dunk
- Don't spoil it for
me. I want to read it.
- Okay. Well essentially like
I'm not going to tell you
how the story goes
because it's a lot to unpack,
but basically like slam dunk.
I really liked the final
chapter of slam dunk
because it was kind of
like experimental almost
because almost.
- Another dimension, where
the basketball slam dunk.
- No, because really made that
like final chapter famous was the fact
that almost the entirety
of the final chapter has no dialogue.
Yeah. Oh, that's cool.
And it's just like it, like
basically he was just like
let me just show you the story rather
than telling you the story.
I don't have the problem
with the final chapter.
I just felt like without
the wrap-up or I felt
like they could have gone
further with the entire story.
And I feel like he just kind of ran
out of ideas and just
kind of just ended it.
You know what I mean?
But it's not that it wasn't
a great final chapter.
It was just that I, I
wanted to spend more time
with these characters and I felt like
there could have been
room to spend more time.
- That was me with Hikaru No Go.
- Oh my God.
If we're talking about, if we're talking
about absolute cuckold endings,
like Hikaru No Go.
- Oh my God.
- Hikaru No Go is a show.
No, no, no, a go Manga.
It's a-
- You know what a go is?
- Yeah, a go.
Yeah, yeah, of course.
- Like a black and white.
- This is when the ghost teaches him.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The one where the ghost
teaches him.
- Doesn't end well?
It
(laughing)
It just ends.
- Oh okay.
- It just ends.
- Say no more.
- You know what I mean?
It just ends in like a
really controversial way.
- Ah, I see.
- Where
people were kind of just
like, wow, there must've been
some like strings behind
the scenes that were kind
of just like, you're
going to end it this way
whether you like it or not, because it's
very, very unsatisfactory.
- Yeah.
- That's sad.
- Nobody was happy.
- Are there any good endings
that you can think of,
off the top of your heads?
Aside from Oyasumi Punpun.*
Because I know you were about
to mention Oyasumi Punpun.
That's the first thing.
I think when I think
of the most genius ending,
it's Oyasmi Punpun.
- I haven't read like many Manga.
Compared to Jerry, but I don't know.
I'm happy enough if it just
doesn't completely fuck itself.
- Yeah. I honestly, is that
how it is that how it is to
be a Manga fan?
Like where you're just like, as long
as it doesn't completely
fuck everything up,
I'll be okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Even if it's like average.
I'm still satisfied with it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Because like I just
recently finished watching
reading Beastars.
Just the last volume
came out like a week ago.
- Yeah.
- Not the strongest ending in my opinion
but it wasn't a complete
shit show of an ending.
So I was like, you know what?
I'm satisfied.
Like
- Okay.
- Could have been better
but it could have been
a lot worse as well, so.
- Is the ending of a Mongo that important?
Cue v* salsa music
(laughing)
- I feel like if an
ending of a manga or even
an anime is good, that can
bring it up from like a, from
like a decent show to
like a master piece level.
- I agree.
- Yeah, go on. Go on.
- I mean, I mean the biggest
example I can think of
is the clusterfuck that
was code yellow season two.
Yeah. And yet somehow the
like I will never forget it
because of how great the ending was.
Same with something like Cowboy
Bebop, for example, as well.
- I think the ending matters more in anime
than it does in Manga.
- What do you think is the difference?
- I don't know.
- I think the way you
- Length.
- Length the way that you experienced it.
I remember vastly the best
bits were Manga more than I do.
Like I said, I, when I look back on Manga,
I remember it it's like an amalgamation
of like the whole experience
as opposed to episodes and like scenes.
- Right.
- And also, yeah.
So I just find that when I finish a Manga
I'd rarely ever think about
the ending of any of them.
I just think about my favorite
moments throughout the Manga.
- Really? I'm the complete opposite.
- I think about the ending.
I think with manga, I think
about like certain scenes
whereas with anime, I think
about it kind of as a whole.
And I think maybe it's
because I binge anime.
So I kind of experienced
the anime all at once.
Whereas with manga, a lot of
it, because it's rather long
for me, a couple of episodes,
- I binge both. So I guess ending's
always important to me.
- Yeah.
Especially if I've felt like
I've spent like a lot of time
with these characters, like,
like it doesn't have to be a
it doesn't have to be
like an amazing ending
but what I want is a satisfying ending.
But if there's an ending
that is actually amazing
and sticks with me, then I'll
always remember that Mongo
- This is true.
Because I read all of Vinland
Saga, which is amazing.
- Yeah.
- Up to the point where it
was out like a few months ago.
- Yeah.
- And if I, if I never read it again
I'd probably be happy knowing
that I had a good story
up to where it, or up to where
I got to, which sounds weird
because it literally was in
the middle of like a fight.
I was like, you know what?
I've read a lot.
I've read so much of this.
That I'm actually satisfied
if I just stop reading
this manga, I'll be okay.
- Yeah.
- Like I'm fine.
- But I guess that's where the
double-edged sword in right?
Is that the longer the
mung, it goes for the more
greater of an ending you expect.
- Almost, I guess.
- Sometimes
or sometimes you just,
cause sometimes you are
you've read a manga for
so long that you kind
of just want it to end.
You can (mumbles)
- I get it.
(laughing)
You kind of just, cause
that was me with Narato.
That was me with Bleach,
you know what I mean?
Where they, they got to a
point when I was just like
I am reading this purely because
I've invested so much time
and it it's it's, it's
the league problem right?
You're just like, I've
invested so much time in this
that I just need to, I
just need to play it out.
- What would you say is the cap then?
Know? You just know it's
like a feeling, right?
Like when I was reading Eyeshield,
I like when it goes to
like chapter, like 250
I'm like, all right, let's wrap it up.
(laughing)
But it had like another a hundred left.
- Right. Right.
- I like this felt like
it went on long enough.
Like it felt like they were
adding too many things like
and a lot of Manga had that where like
what was once a gigantic threat earlier on
even though they haven't changed much
in power will suddenly be
like, they dispatch it.
And like once one hit,
- Right.
There's so many stuff
like that where it's like
so this really cool enemy you introduce
you start just one shotting later on.
It's like, what's the point of this?
Like you're just completely
ruining all the steaks over
and over again.
I hate it.
Well, so some reason, man,
some fucking action scenes
are like nigh on impossible to figure out
what the fuck is going on in manga.
Like I'm, I'm, I'm looking
(laughing)
at these panels and the shit going on.
And I'm like, I would need to
like get out my fucking pen
and draw along to like try
and figure out what the
actual cartography is.
- Like a bird's eye view and
you showing me like layout
of what's happening.
- I mean,
- I would have more chance having
like a battlefield view
and you showing me like
little fucking statues moving.
- Right.
- So fans trying to figure out*
- Before the anime, yeah.
- That was literally me
I was like, what's going on?
At manga?
I'm like, I will sit
there for a good, like 30
seconds staring at this.
Like yeah, I have no fucking idea.
- That's the problem I
have with like Jojolion.
Cause I was I'm reading it.
I'm like these stand pals,
like getting so fucking weird
that I'm looking at something and I'm like
I guess the stand is doing its power
but I don't know what the fuck?
- What are you doing?
Because then an action Manga.
I started like not really care about.
Cause half the time you can barely
tell what's actually happening.
And you're just like putting the dots.
I don't know.
There's something about
watching the fight unfold and
like the way it was meant
to in like a time way
with music and noise was
so much more satisfying.
- I dunno.
Cause I feel like that is the problem
with a lot of anime fights period, right?
Is that they don't
actually feel like flights.
They feel like just
they feel like impacts
intermittently with, with dialogue.
In between.
- Basically.
You know what I mean?
Cause like no one know it,
you see some anime flights
and you think no one
actually fights like this.
You know what I mean?
No one throws
A punch, says a sentence
then throws a punch back.
You know what I mean?
That, that doesn't know how fights work.
- Literally every Bucky fight.
(laughing)
- Exactly.
- What's a fight without
a dialogue? Come on gone.*
- Because it's like,
that's why for example
the fights in God of high
school really stood out
to me cause they actually felt
like a martial arts fight.
You know what I mean?
Let's say what you want about
the story or the whatever
but the way the fights
were directed and frames
and just choreographed, they
felt like actual fights.
- It felt like it felt like
a Jackie Chan fight, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
And I'm cause that's what,
that's what immediately stood
out to me about that direction.
And that animation was that,
you know, sometimes you get
like the narrative episode
where you have like
you have like the basic
normal narrative fights.
And then you have like this
one episode that is just
like this, the studio putting
all their budget and their
a team on one fucking fight.
And then that you
that that is the fight
that people will remember.
You know what I mean?
But most anime fights are just, I mean
they are literally just
animated manga panels
and you can't tell what's going on
in a manga panel with
action most of the time.
So that's really what sets the good fights
from the bad fights.
- Sometimes you need that dialogue, right?
To help build it up.
It's like a, it's like a good poem, right?
Sometimes you need the story
to make the worthwhile.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, of course.
- I think there's like a limit to how
much dialogue, like, you
know, that's one thing I
didn't like about like a lot
of Narato fights is the fact
that it's like, I don't
need a fucking flashback
in the middle of a punch.
I don't need that.
(mumbles)
- Yeah. I like it when they're like
internalizing their
thoughts on the battle.
That's more interesting to me than fucking
Like, ah, you're strong.
And it's like, well obviously that's why
You're fucking fighting each other.
My least favorite, like
anime fight trope is like the
the guy in the sidelines
explaining everything
while it's happening.
- To be fair, that that's
either hit or miss.
Cause the only like one of the only
Yeah like, like it's, it's
either Speedwagon or it's shit basically.
- Pretty much.
It's like, it's like
I don't know how this
person is able to like
explain every fucking
like physics movement
as this guy's doing
fucking a one-inch punch.
Right?
- Yeah.
- It's like, it's like,
what is the timeframe?
How is that happening?
- And then there's like,
Bucky, which just like you
you have an e-sports commentator just
like explaining every detail
and technique and the fucking backstory.
- I love that. That's
fucking great. I love it.
- That's the thing like.
(laughing)
if it's like Jojo, Bucky, where it's, it's
it's gone to the point
where it's so unrealistic
that it just becomes ridiculous.
I like that.
I hate it when they try
and make it as if it's
happening in real time.
And it's like, don't kid yourself guys.
Like, isn't it.
Like you'd have to be like rap God
in order to like commentate over it.
That fucking quickly as it's happening.
(laughing)
- Yeah, sometimes you just
hear a piece of dialogue
in the time it takes us for
like one punch to get thrown.
A punch is just like a millisecond.
Right. And they have this five
minute dialogue in the middle
of their head in between this
punch getting thrown in just
- It's like a multi page
like (mumbles)* right?
And it's like, where's the punch?
- Where's the impact?
(mumbles)
- No I'm just like, is
time dilation just a thing
when anime characters
get punched or something?
Like Einstein's rolling in
his grave right now when
when whenever a punch gets thrown man.
(laughing)
- Yeah. And also how many
fucking Manga are there
where like someone gets stabbed
and then like the like
but you fell in my trap
and it's like, how many
how many times have you practiced this?
Where you just been
like stabbed or punched?
And this was like part of your plan.
Like, this is just like
too, it happens so often.
Or like sometimes they'll get
like a fatal wound and they'll
immediately like heal it.
And it's like what?
- Yeah. But then again, right.
It's like, that kind of goes
back into the whole thing
of like how ridiculous it is as well.
Right? Like, Bucky does
that so fucking often
where it's like, you should be dead
after one punch, but you've
somehow managed to survive
like 10 punches, a stab wound
and like three gunshots.
And you're still able
to like form a dialogue.
- Well, I feel like Bucky
is just like one side
of the extreme where it's
so extreme that you can't
take it seriously anymore.
I mean a lot of anime flights on that.
I like anime trips, like anime
is just normalized getting
punched and coughing up blood.
Whereas in real life, you're
internally hemorrhaging and
(laughing)
(panting)
You're probably gonna die.
If you internally
hemorrhage, let's be honest.
- If you cough of blood, bro.
- You're dead.
(laughing)
(mumbles)
- If you smash your head
through a concrete wall
which is apparently normal in anime
then you've got a fucking
concussion, you know.
- Or, or just a splattered head.
(laughing)
No head probably.
- Exactly.
- I want a realistic
like toe stubbing scene in anime
(laughing)
That's what I want.
That's what I want to experience.
- What about? I mean, niche-y
Joe* could have done it.
- Yeah. Probably.
- Toe stubbing is like the closest I get
to a real life anime scene. Right?
- I want someone to just animate
someone's stubbing their toe.
And that it's just like immediately
like a Jojo sight, like cough up blood
(groaning)
- I'm pretty sure like
Bubba, Bubba, Bubba, boy
probably did something like that.
- I dunno what it is
about stubbing your toe.
Like you stop your toe.
And it's one of the few injuries
you get where you do it.
And you know, the pain is coming.
But for some reason there is a pain delay
between you'd stubbing, your
toe and the immense pain.
You're about to feel
like if there was time
for a real life, anime flashback,
it's in that delay.
(laughing)
It's in that pain delay map*.
- Now, if you were an anime
character, you would realize
that you can synchronize
your energy to counter the
blow incoming. That's...
Come on.
- You can stop the nervous system
from delivering it to your brain.
- Exactly.
- Yeah. That's that's the closest you get
to a fucking anime injury or whatever.
- I wonder do you guys want to talk
about Attack on Titan?
Because Twitter's funny
right now, Twitter is funny.
I mean what is there to talk about? Like.
- I didn't realize
How much for the clown Fiesta Twitter is
about Attack on Titan.
How are, how is, how have people
turned this into a thing to like dislike?
I don't understand like-
- Like I knew there was something wrong
When I woke up in the morning
and went on to Twitter.
Hashtag thank you Mapa was trending.
I was like, what the fuck
are these clowns doing now?
- It's like every time, every
time Attack on Titan airs,
and you go on Twitter
and something about tack
on Titan is trending.
- And the time of recording
is episode six came out.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And basically the most
recent thing that happened
was what was it?
People, people
on Twitter were just
attacking the staff members.
They were-
- Why? What's wrong with them?
- I think what I've read
was some people were just
harassing the director for one
of the music choices that was
that was made in one of the big scenes.
And it got so bad that he had
to deactivate his Twitter.
- He did?
- Yeah.
- And a bunch of animators
as well are getting harassed.
- I'm literally watching this thing.
Like, this is amazing.
Why are people getting angry?
Like, is there like what
was wrong with the song?
- Like I can't
(sighs)
Who the fuck the knows?
- Maybe it's like, I'm losing words
because it's so fucking dumb.
- Stupid.
And I'm the-
You can't do that.
You don't deserve anime.
I'm just saying right now, like you just
you just don't deserve that.
- You ain't a real anime fan,
You're not a real anime
fan if you do that.
- What blows my mind is that like
at the end of the day, a
lot of these people, right?
We're just, we're just anime fans.
Why on earth?
Do you think you have the right to that?
Just go to like the director level.
I fucking hate that.
- The fucking audacity.
- How dare you.
- You try and make an anime.
(laughing)
And see how you, if you
can make a good light
I want to do is like, I
just want to like kind of
cause I think one
of the things I saw yesterday
was people were complaining
about one of the Titans
being like really bad CGI
or whatever
- Yeah. I'm watching this thing, right?
And the CGI is honestly
like barely noticeable.
It's really like, not even remotely, like
- Yeah.
I just want to like go off
to all those people
complaining about the CGI
and like link them to any
scene from like Bizarre 2016.
- Yeah. Like this is one,
the same people who've will
The clip.
Right. And then run it
through Sony Vegas, call it 4k.
And re-upload it.
And be like, this is a 4k fight scene guy.
- That's my least favorite thing.
- It's it's absolutely absurd.
- 60 fps, 4K fight scene.
(laughing)
- Which is like (mumbles)
- Let's go baby.
- The descriptions like
I fixed this fight.
I made it better.
- Dumbest fucking thing.
- Don't do that.
- I, yeah.
I mean I was
cause I tweeted out saying like,
Attack on Titan B will
be carrying on in 2021.
Obviously not being a hundred
percent serious about that.
I'm not, I'm not literally
sitting there being like my 2021
would be ruined if Attack
on Titan wasn't airing.
Like there's some, my God.
The arguments that
arose in those comments.
- I made like an Attack on Titan
tweet immediately muted it.
I was just like, I've done this
enough times before to know
that saying anything about
tackling Titan, whether positive
or negative, you just set up,
you just set up a minefield.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- It's like, I, you know, I tweeted it.
I came back four hours
later and then, you know
as I'm, you know, cause
you refresh your Twitter
you see the most recent reply.
And it was something
about like Japanese whaling
laws that they were arguing
about. And then I clicked on it.
- Excuse me.
(laughing)
- I click on this thing
and it goes up like
50 replies back and forth.
These two people going at it
because one of them said that
like Ray zero season two
was going to be better.
And they somehow devolved
into like an attack on Japan.
And I was like, what
the fuck is happening?
- Do these people have
like anything else to do?
- I just, I just don't understand
how people can be angry
about like a great thing.
Like even if they're CGI in
it, that is barely noticeable.
What's wrong, it's getting
adapted and it looks good.
We're getting what we want.
I mean, I do understand why
people are being so pathetic.
- I feel like this is coming from
the perspective of a lot of
let's say more like entitled
manga readers, right?
Cause you can be disappointed
in some ways of an anime
adaptation, because there, there
there are some times when you read a manga
and you have an imagination
about how this Mongo is going to play out
if it was animated and with something
like attack on Titan where the bar
by studio wits was set
so fucking high, right?
That you go to mapper
which I still think mapper is
doing a fucking fantastic job.
We've had bangers.
- We've had fucking bangers.
And what I will say is like
it's like the tiniest of nitpicks, right.
Where I would say that it's
gone from like a 10 out of 10
adaptation to like a nine
out of 10 adaptation.
And that, that that's, that's,
that's the thing, right?
It's, it's, it's a very
slight step down from where it
it's not bad by any step.
It's just a very slight step down.
It's like
- Like the people taking that as
if it went from like a 10 to a one.
- Yeah, yeah, Exactly, right?
And the thing is it's a
nine hour 10 adaptation
for 10 out of 10 material.
You're still getting a fucking banger.
- I don't fucking get it.
- It's not seven deadly
sins, season three.
So I don't, I really do not
understand the problem here.
And like, you know
these are the people who
were getting this nitpicky
on Twitter and those
manga readers are just
the exact same kind of
people who are just like
when their kids born, if
that kid fucks up anything
they're like, well, it's ruined.
It's fucked.
(laughing)
I, you know, my expectations were fucked.
It's ruined, what can I say?
- What I-
- Well, they just like
this isn't like what was in the bottle.
- They're basing it off their own life.
If, if the child fucks up,
they're like, well fuck it didn't
stick to the (mumbles)
- Looking at the ultrasound,
they're seen the baby born.
It's like, well, that's,
that's not, that's not
a good adaptation, is it?
(laughing)
- So, you're saying to me
it's not gonna be six foot.
Honestly. Just put it back in
- This isn't exactly the same.
- That's the go go
completely on a tangent.
That's all I completely feel
about gender reveal parties.
I don't, I don't understand
the point of gender reveal.
- I've seen so many fucking
like absurd gender robot, gender reveal
party clips on like
tick-tok and stuff like that
where I'm just like, this
is just hilarious now.
Did you see the one where
it's like, fuck what was it?
It was like, there was like a, a balloon
like a giant fucking balloon.
You know like, you know, maybe like six-
- This is the weirdest fucking
tangent we've ever done.
- No, because what I was,
what I was thinking was like.
- You took too long.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
(laughing)
- No, was just gonna say,
like, there's just like a giant
like six, seven foot balloon
that this guy carries.
- Yeah.
And he's just like, all
right, I'm going to pop it.
And it just explodes
into this like colored
like powder that just completely
fills up the backyard.
- Cause what I'm thinking right.
Is okay.
The point of gender
reveal party is to reveal
the gender of the baby, right?
- Right.
- And celebrate that.
But like at which point do do,
does like agenda get revealed
and the father is just
like, Oh, it's, it's a girl.
- No!
- Oh, Karen, Karen, go
get the current hanger.
We're doing it again.
Like what, what kind of, what kind
of reaction do you expect the
father and the mother to have?
You know what I mean?
- It's like what human?
Most normal people will be
like, whether it's a guy
or a girl do reaction's
going to be the same.
- You're gonna have a kid.
- I just think that we
celebrate too many things.
I think we have enough
things to celebrate.
How hard is it to just say, it's a boy.
How hard is it?
- Is like having the kids
birthday like not enough?
(laughing)
Like I think to me, I
legitimately don't understand
like we have so many things to celebrate.
It's fucking exhausting. Who
is planning all this shit?
Like who has this much free time?
Honestly, I barely can like
get Christmas plans together.
Like my own birthday. Who has this?
Is it the woman she's pregnant?
Shouldn't you be focused on that?
Like I don't. I don't get it.
- I wonder if there's like
self fulfilling prophecy
of why some people working
in retail in America
when a person comes in and being like
give me all of your blue dye.
I need as much blue dye as possible.
And they're like, oh fuck.
One of these all right.
- But yeah, back to Attack on Titan.
(laughing)
- That was such a weird transition.
- That was a weird tangent.
Bottom line, stop complaining
about Attack on Titan.
It's good. It's fine
- I just felt like, I
just feel like it's like
cause you know, I think
it's a of edge edge
of people out there who are
just like, I don't want to admit
that Attack on Titan is
the best thing right now.
I don't want to give it
more clout than it deserves.
And you know, you see these
fucking God awful takes
on Twitter being like,
yeah, it was boring.
Dropped it right away.
And it's like, who cares?
Just let the people who are enjoying it.
Fucking enjoy it.
- Well.
- It's good.
- Yeah. It's like-
- Stop shitting on it.
That's the thing.
It's like, you can have you can have
an opinion about it, right?
Like if you think it's shit, whatever.
Don't fucking harass
the animators over it.
- Yeah. It's same thing with like
when Game of Thrones is like around.
People like, you know,
people just want to be that
person who's like, yeah.
I don't like game of Thrones.
Yeah. Whatever, it sucked.
- Cool.
- Oh you happy about it?
Fuck. That's lame bro.
I'm not excited about it.
I'm not excited about anything.
Bro, except my gender reveal,
party.
- Fuck the system.
- Yeah.
Everything I get excited for
is my baby's gender like that.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't know.
Yeah. For some reason, you
know, I mean it does happen
in other genres as well,
but for some reason
who are these I don't
even know the fucking @s
of these creators that Tweet.
How are they finding this shit?
Why, why are they finding this shit?
Just to fucking @ them and
tell them that it's shit.
- Right. As if like one of the
animes is going to be like,
Oh, thanks for your feedback.
We'll change it immediately.
They go to the annual meeting
like yo guys, you see him?
These people don't like it.
What the fuck?
- Yeah. So like MiCasa276 on
Twitter said that we should
we should just completely
change the episode.
It just changed studios.
Like what director's going to be like RFM.
I've got you.
- I mean, it kind of sucks that, you know
in the time where the Japanese industry
and the Japanese staff members
are starting to, you know
we want them to open up to
to open up more to the
international community.
This is the they have to deal
with for some of like the
biggest profile adaptation.
- I kinda want to just go there
and be like, don't open up.
- Yeah
(laughing)
It's not worth it. Don't open up.
- Don't go to Twitter.
I do think You know, there's a
good amount of the people who
are probably sending hate,
who probably don't want it to open up.
Cause to them, I think it's,
you know, it's the same thing
with like the idol and like kind of almost
like the whole life fan
base a little bit where
they're like
we don't want all our people
to interact outside, ruin them.
- We don't want the normies coming in
- We don't want, we don't.
- Yeah.
- We don't want like the
American corporations
getting their fingers in our Japanese,
like anime, you know what I mean?
There's a lot of people
who are like that, right.
- As if they're Japanese, themselves.
- I mean, they bought at the time
it does come from a place of
- non Japanese.
- Yeah, non Japanese.
- We like all-
I get it if they were
Japanese, but most, if not, all of
It's like in your video, when you did the
the anime studio tour and like
the guy who was the director
of the studio, it was like,
Oh we have foreign fans?
- Yeah. I like genuinely.
Yeah. So the CEO of CloverWorks
genuinely didn't know
that they had fans.
- I mean, a lot of people don't know that
- Can you blame them if
he goes on 20 (mumbles)
Give him time to kill himself. What?
I would be like, no,
they don't exist. Don't.
- No. They don't honestly
- Honestly like,
It's embarrassing.
- I'm just saying you do
to make you feel better.
- I mean, I suppose if you think about it,
it's the same wave.
It's the same mentality
of like, for example
if we find out that Trash Taste has
or something had Japanese
fans, you know what I mean?
It's just like, Oh, there's
people in Japan who watch us.
We have Russian fans?
- We have a Russian dump
what's going on here?
- I get emails every week.
I'm like, you guys know you
have like a Russian doll.
Yeah. We get it.
- Its fine.
- Would you say that Attack
on Titan is carrying your 2021
- So far.
Yeah. Dude, every episode I'm
getting fucking hyped for.
- Well, she just, you
know, be appreciative
of the fact that we're even
getting Attack on Titan.
Right? Like in the midst of a pandemic.
- Yeah I mean, the fact is
that Attack on Titan it's it
could be carrying any year
because I don't think
that anything can live up
to what Attack on Titan season
four is giving us right now.
And I say this in the
midst of what I would-
- One of the strongest
seasons we've ever had.
- I would argue that this is the front.
This is a contender for one
of the strongest seasons
in the history of anime.
- Yeah.
And that is a big statement.
But like it's so stacked
in every single genre
and every single kind
of every single category
you can think of that.
I can't think of a single person
who can't find at least two
or three shows that there'll
be watching this season.
And then on top of that, you
have the classic being made.
That is Attack on Titan.
- Why would you, I, you know
if I was an anime studio
and I found out when
Attack on Titan airing,
I'd be like, you know what?
Just fucking hold on.
(laughing)
Don't don't let's wait
like on YouTube, you know
if you upload a video
when like Shane Dawson
dropped a documentary.
It's like, just don't.
Just don't.
- That's like movie
companies being like, wait
Avengers in cinemas right now,
pull back pull back, pull back.
Never release at the
same time as Avengers,
cause like, no one's going to watch it.
Like almost I would have been like
just hold off because the
Attack on Titan going to carry
like even if I only get
to watch it once a week
it's going to be in my
mind the whole week.
So like just hold off and give
me a banger of next season.
But now they, all, everyone was like
let's all come out right now.
Let's let's all have all
our bangers right now
In this one season.
Cause like the amount of like
we we've had a few seasons previously
with some season twos here and there
but it seems like every season two
or like sequel the season
is a fucking banger.
- Because like Beastars
is airing right now.
Right. Okay. So
- I do not know any
- No one is talking about it.
Cause Attack on Titan
- Yeah.
is the only thing that
anyone gives a shit about.
- Okay. So we got Beastars two.
Which is gotta be amazing.
We've got Promise Neverland.
- Which no one is talking about.
- No one's talking about
- Remember when promise Netherland
came out, it was massive.
it was the only one spoke about.
- Yeah
- We got Lock Horizon three, Quints two.
Quintessential Quintuplets two.
We got Dr. Stone two
- Yeah.
- I sleep.
- I sleep Attack on Titan season two.
I awoke.
- Awoke.
- Yeah. Basically.
I mean like it's how can you not man?
Like every episode is just
like a fucking roller coaster.
And like for a lot
of people we can on this
for like five plus years.
This journey, right?
- It's it's and it's, and it's one
of the few ones where it feels
like it's run its natural course
actually it's actually coming to an end.
You know what I mean?
And I said in a tweet that I feel
like this is like watching
a classic being made.
And I have no doubts that if like, even
if he doesn't like completely
slammed dunk the ending, even
if it's just an okay satisfying ending,
it's going to go down.
- As long as it's not like
the crummiest fucking ending imaginable.
- Yeah.
- Which I-
- Wait for it. Multi-verse
predicted multi-verse.
- I would like to think
not going to happen.
- I completely forgot Re Zero
two is airing this season.
- Oh, yeah.
- Again, you just can't compete.
- No one's talking about it.
- No one's talking
about anything.
And I'm just like
there's so many bangers to season
and like Attack on Titan.
It's just taking over.
- Like I'm sure. Because I remember
I was watching the last season
of Breaking Bad as it
was airing, week by week.
I'm sure I watched other
TV shows during that time.
I cannot tell you what
I've watched other than
than fucking Breaking Bad.
- Yeah, true true.
- Like it was like the highlight, right?
Like it's what it takes up your
your space and your hype for
like or for what's going to
it's going to be 26 episodes,
Attack on Titan right?
- No, it's going to be 14.
- It's 14?
- Yeah. So right now,
from what I've heard, like
this is me going off of whatever-
- Speculation warning.
- Manga, manga readers.
So it's going to be 14
episodes, I think 14 or 15
which doesn't take it up
to the end of the Manga.
Cause the end of the manga ends in April
Cause I'm poor...
- Yeah, I heard that.
- April or May.
I can't remember, but it's confirmed
that the Manga is going to
be ending this late spring
summer kind of time.
- I thought they were trying
to do like a duel ending,
where it was going to be.
They both were like
ending it the same itme.
- Like an anime originally.
- No, no, no, no.
- No.
Like it was gonna, he was probably gonna
I thought he meant maybe he was gonna
like tell them the studio, the end date.
- No. So what's so with the confirmed
amount of episodes, that's out so far
what people are thinking
is going to happen is
either we're going to get
a season four part two.
- Fuck.
- Or we are going to get a movie.
- No.
- I would I'm speculating
it's going to be a movie.
- And I think a movie is
(groaning)
going to be more likely.
- I mean look
how fucking successful Demon Slayer was.
- I know. I know.
- They get to see that.
- I don't wanna movie!
And they probably saw then was like,
we can do that with the
last Attack on Titan thing.
Just saying.
- Honestly. Like if-
- I'm gonna have to speed
run the Hong go real quick.
Fuck
(laughing)
- I'm going (mumbles)
- Like Joey was saying
- There's a fucking type it out.
- Please live translate for me.
Come on. Yeah.
I'll hire a professional light.
You know the ones that the governments
when they go to the meetings
I'll hire them to get in the
seat behind me in the theater.
Just whispering in my ear.
- All I get to say is
like personal reasons.
I wish I hope it's
going to be a movie just
so I can be the first one
to make a video on it.
(laughing)
(yelling)
- I'm going to go to
the midnight screening.
And I'm going to make a video
and be like, yeah guys, it was epic.
(laughing)
- Where-
- I would not do that.
- I'm kidding. I'm joking.
- I wouldn't, I would
not ruin possibly one
of the greatest animes to go down
in history just for YouTube click.
But I'd be like, Hey guys, I
think I know what happened.
I watched it all three times.
I think I got the gist
of what's going on with Made in Abyss.
- Yeah we watched it together.
- What the is this movie called? Dawn in-
- Okay. We watched the
Made in Abyss movie.
We'd like, obviously there's no subtitles.
I'm pretty sure I
understood what happened.
(laughing)
I'm pretty happy.
I'm pretty sure I got it.
- I got the gist.
- Was like plot, plot,
questionable child, Paul plot.
And then (mumbles)
(laughing)
- And I was just like, Oh Kevin,
you did, you did a good job
Cause Kevin was sitting right next to us.
- Damn, this song is good, man.
- It's like go into hall.
Questionable child hall. Music, good.
(laughing)
- Basically, but yeah like everyone
The Made in Abyss movie was amazing
and I'm just like had a good,
I still haven't seen it.
Honestly. It's fine.
(laughing)
- I mean, I'm not going
to take your word for it.
(laughing)
- As a man who understood
half of what was being said,
(laughing)
it was fine.
- This episode of Trash
Taste is sponsored by G fuel.
What flavor are you drinking Guk?
I am drinking starfruit flavor right now.
- I'm drinking pink lemonade.
- Wow. I'm drinking faze berry.
- If you want your own G fuel
you can use co Trash Tastes
to get 30% off G fuel.
- Thanks G-fuel.
- Link's in the description
back to the episode.
- Can we talk about the real masterpiece
airing the season though?
- Masterpiece?
- Oh, and Joey.
(laughing)
Joey knows what I'm talking about.
- It's really funny cause
(laughing)
I was just to bring it up too.
- So, forget this Attack on Titans lando.
Like whatever we're going
to call the classic.
The real classic that's coming
out the season is an anime called
X arm.
- X arm!
- So I'm a, I'm a complete newb
now I have seen clips of it
But could you please explain
to me what Xarm is and it's total ness.
- It is hilarious.
(laughing)
- It is an experience. I will say that.
So I think we have literally
got the mass effect
Andromeda releases of anime.
You know what I mean?
- The Cyber Punk finish.
(laughing)
So this is, I didn't know.
Anime
Could have bugs and glitches.
That's all I'm gonna say.
(laughing)
- So it is a crunchy roll original
right?
- Oh no. Oh no.
- And you know that crunchy roll up proud
of this because I have
not seen a single piece
of promotional work about this at all.
- I saw the trailer on YouTube
but I thought it was a joke.
(laughing)
And the show looks
Worse than that.
- No.
- Yeah.
- It looks, it looks worse than
- I hate to say to you about the trailer's
probably the best part about the show
the trailer isn't the trailer.
The trailer is the anime
(mumbles)
But that probably makes it
makes it good, doesn't it?
- But it's so bad.
- I was crying and
laughter the first episode.
- It is like I think the third
lowest anime on mal right now
after one episode
- After one episode.
- Yeah, but you're laughing.
- So I mean it's, it's
a that's that's what
it's a masterpiece of trash basically.
It's it's fucking.
it's no masterpiece.
(laughing)
It is a masterpiece.
It's like, it's like
the first time I watched
like Ghazi's wing, right?
- Yeah. All like, you
know, Skelter heaven.
I was like a scale to
heaven, I was like, this is
I'm watching a masterpiece,
but on the opposite
end of the.
- So, so to, to explain Xarm,
there's a control original
anime that is made
by a completely new studio
by a team who's never
worked in anime before.
- American?
- No Japanese.
- Japanese team.
But they've never worked in anime before.
And it shows, it shows,
(laughing)
it shows that
They've never worked anime before.
And it is a 3D anime
that looks like it was
made by a five-year-old
who just learned Blender. Like yesterday.
- Oh no. Oh no.
- It makes Ruby look like
it makes Ruby season one
look like an absolute master class.
- I was going to watch
it, but I just wanted to
get like drunk enough just
to like fully enjoy it.
- It makes Bezerk 2016 looked like Akira.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- What?
- It's pretty bad.
- And what's worse is that like
I posted the clip of it on Twitter
but like there's a scene right
near the beginning, right?
Where the main character is
3D, but his brother is in 2D.
- What?
(laughing)
- So you have this truly awful CG,
like blocky Minecraft character standing
next to this 2D anime character.
And he literally in the
same scene, the same shot.
And he literally looks
he literally looks green screened
on, you know what I mean?
It looks like someone just learned
it looked like someone
just had learned this
the Chrome Mickey's.
- He said to his boss. Like yo,
you heard of this thing
called a chroma key.
This is nuts.
- Exactly.
- Look
- You can see it on screen right now.
Oh my God. That's awful.
That's like, that looks
like in the same scene.
You know what that is, that looks like
if you told me that was
what's that what's that
game where everyone can have
their own avatars in the game.
It looks like the like second life,
whatever it's called, yeah?
(laughing)
it looks like if like, you know how
like someone other people
have their own servers
and they like 2D things and
they have like the 3D models.
That's what it looks like.
- You know what that looks like?
That looks like someone
took like a regular anime
and made like an MMD edit
of it. Know what I mean?
- I can see it. I can see it.
- Cause it is like that quality.
Actually, MMD is a better quality.
- Mmd is a better anime.
It's pretty damn good MMDs out there.
Don't be hating on my MMD.
- And then like, if, if
that wasn't already bad
there was just like some
of the fight choreography
is just hilarious.
Like this is one fight scene.
I think like it's like
the last fight scene
of the first episode where
there was just no music.
It's like, they forgot
to put in the music.
(laughing)
It's just like, like that, but
there's no music whatsoever.
So it's just, I was watching
it and I was just like
there's something wrong
with my headphones?
Like why is there no music playing?
- I remember like in
the last part they run
out or something and it's
literally a guy who looks like
it looks like it's literally
looks like the characters are
like being animated with a
steak or something like that.
There's literally no
like they're not moving
their limbs or something.
They just like rocking from side to side.
- So, are we talking about like that?
Like Queen Bee would put them to shame.
Oh, I wish this was
automated by Queen Bee.
It makes queen bee look
like studio wit. It's fucking horrible.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- But it's also just a really fun time.
Like I had a lot of fun
watching the first episode.
- I mean, I want to get some drinks
and just enjoy it, you know?
- Oh, we need to its so funny.
- This would be like even
better if it had like kind of
like a ghost stories dub.
So someone needs to dub Exxon
like crunchy roll, please.
Don't be ashamed of XR.
You are sitting on a golden duck here
just marketed correctly.
And people will mean the out of us.
Give us the rights to dub Waldoboro.
- We'll make an amazing dub of it.
You know What I mean?
Can't wait to direct those sessions.
(laughing)
- And like the opening song as well.
Just what?
(laughing)
That, the one that sounds like
some, some 41, it sounds like
it sounds like sum 41 cover band.
I heard that was the one that
used for the trailer, right?
Yeah. That is just the anime
Tried to send me it.
And he's like, what the is this?
What the?
What is this?
God.
It's like, it's
like a high school band that
listened to too much green day.
You know what mean?
It does sound like a cover band.
Oh my God.
That is perfect.
But so why is no one talking about that?
I don't know that you have attachment type
of season four, but who gives a about
Greenlit? That like, I know, sorry.
Like who, who let that through
light quality assurance?
Like who led that through
what qualities I'm saying?
Like just normally
people who are like, yeah
this is good to go.
Who, who dead watch that
first episode was like, yeah.
It's good.
I wonder though, if someone
at like the production
team was like, I feel like
we're forgetting something
- QA. Oh shit.
You know how sometimes when
like people like make shows
but it's just one big
like tax fraud scheme.
It's like, I shouldn't say
that you get in trouble.
It's definitely a joke.
It's a joke.
Oh my God.
But like, I wonder what the people working
on it think of this, you know what I mean?
Cause you know, sometime,
sometimes you work
on a project that you're proud
about, you know what I mean?
Cause it
People want to get paid gone.
Right. Or the end of the
day, they're like, I mean
I got to just keep toning
up and doing what they ask.
Right. That's what I imagine
It's happening.
I don't know.
I just like to imagine that
like the animators came back
to the, like the producer
and was like, yeah, the,
the, the models look great.
So like put some shading on it
put a little more animation
on the producers light.
So it's coming out tomorrow.
I just want, I just want
to know, because you know
in like in any like anime production
or any big project production,
you know, you have this
you have this screening nights, right?
Where you as a group, as the team
you get to watch the final
product before it airs.
I just want to hear the silence
in that room when the credits roll
and you just, you just,
what, what can you say?
Psych in Japan?
Always silent.
That's what I see in America and the West.
We have clapping, right?
Because like the thing that the entire
like screen your room is just
like silently nodding their head.
Hell yeah.
Every Japanese means just
waiting for the visa card.
Anyway, come on.
I just want to be a man.
I'm going to get a free meal
at the end of the screening
and free drinks.
So it doesn't matter
like that, that tuning
up to the screen.
I turn up to the screening.
If I could
Listen, man, like as
someone who's like, you know
Donna document, you're
going to name a studio.
I completely see
Oh, look at that flat.
It's hard. I get it.
It's hard.
But also come on.
(laughing)
It's hard but come on, man.
It's hard. You know, we're not
we're not blaming the
probably staff at all.
I'm not blaming anyone for it.
If anything, I'd like to thank them
for giving us some like
quality entertainment.
Honestly, it is honestly quality.
I watched episode two
and it is also a banger.
Just coming out with a bang.
The episode, man
Exxon episode two is what
I'm looking forward to.
Are you guys watching
anything else this season
or are you guys waiting
to see what gets hype?
And we'll get one to watch what the
called one drag priority.
That is one direct priority.
Weirdest fucking title,
but I watched the trailer
on it because I heard so many people.
A lot of people were asking me like, Hey
have you seen the first episode?
This I was like, that doesn't
even sound like a real anime.
One direct wondering
party that sounds made up.
But then I checked out the trailer.
I was like, actually,
this kind of looks fire.
Yeah. It's
It's too early to tell
how it's going to go
because I've watched the first episode
about that is it's it's one
of those shows where I'm just like
I don't even know what,
you know what I mean?
It's, it's one of those weird
I asked people, I was
like, what's it about?
And people just said, just watch it.
It feels like a
like an eco horror show
or something like that.
I don't like Sarah's
on my or something or something like that.
I'm just, I'm just throwing out words.
Like the keeps me
like a slight light
tatami galaxy vibe to it.
You know?
Like kind of just like
it's like so strange that
it's hard to describe what I
what I will say it, it feels
like, it feels like Madoka
Magica directed by eco horror.
It's it's really
- What the fuck you guys talking about?
So you can hire is the
director that may penguin drum.
What else has he made?
What else has he for hire made melee?
What's that magical girl. One day.
It doesn't matter.
You don't, you've not
seen any of his work.
Yeah. Right.
But he makes a lot of weird stuff
and it's I watched the first episode
and it it's the, what I will say.
I can't really sport with it
because I don't even
understand the first episode.
You know what I mean?
But it's a story that
it presents the events
of this world out of order.
Hmm. So you get
Oh my God.
I'm like racking my brain to figure
out how I can describe this show.
It's kind of presented.
Story-like like a boogie
pot Phantom kind of
it's it's it is very
reminiscent of biggie.
Like if you have no context
of what you're talking about
it actually just sounds
like you guys are talking about gibberish
Alamo. You've watched come on away.
I don't fucking know.
Like a lot of the
when people are like,
dude, you gotta wash this
animates. So
It's kind of like on the same vein
as serial experiments
lane boogie, pop Phantom.
I, I feel like you just haven't
You put those shows on
you're like, there's no way
you could enjoy this without
doing like four tabs of acid.
You know what I mean?
Like a lot of shows are like that
Maybe with serial experiments lane
but I'd argue that like something
like boogie bull Phantom is,
- Don't really concern myself.
Yeah. I mean, it's something
where you have to be
in a very specific mood to enjoy it
because it's not
something you can just put
on and just enjoy it as an insane
as like a coherent story or something.
But what I will say is out of
because I put my season
on video, I watched every
the first two episodes of
like every new anime and
out of everything I
watched, it's the one where
I watched it didn't
know what was going on.
Didn't fully understand it, but I
it stuck with me, you know?
It, it, it really, it
was really the one where
I kept thinking about
it after it had ended
after I'd watched everything
else, I was just like, nah
I don't know what it is.
But I keep thinking
about wondering priority.
And I dunno what it is exactly
about wondering priority
that makes me latch onto it.
But there's something,
I feel something special
that I kind of, I kind
of got that same feeling.
The first time I watched
like the first episode of
like fully coli, right?
It's like, I dunno what the is happening.
Like the student's forehead
little robot just came out of it.
I can give you a play by play
of what happens in wander rig.
So this girl there's
this like short hooded
like she wears like a yellow hoodie girl.
The first scene is there a Cicada comes
along and starts talking
to her and you're like,
okay, whatever cool.
She can talk to cicadas.
And then she gets given an egg
and then she wonders
what to do with this egg.
And then she's sitting on the toilet
and then toilet people starts talking
to her and she's like, yo, what the?
And then the egg hatches.
And it turns out that it's
a go hatches out the egg.
I think I'll just watch.
I don't want to spoil too
much, but that's what was fun.
I mean, if, if it, you
know, if the weeks go
on and everyone's still
like, yeah, it's a good show.
Yeah.
I mean, I, from what I can
understand, by the first episode
it deals with a lot of themes
of depression and suicide.
And it seems like it's it
we get glimpses into our
backstory because you know
we get glimpses into, is,
is this a dream world?
Or is this the imagining things?
Or what's kind of going
on where we only get hints at everything.
I feel like, again, it's like
it's kind of like a modern
spin on fully Callie, right?
Cause like fully call is kind
of the same where it's like
it kind of used as
like absurd imagery to
present deeper meanings.
It's like I said
it's way too early to tell
what the show is going to be
about and how good it is.
But like I said, out of everything
I watch it stuck out to me the most.
That's the one I thought about
the most, but I don't know
if you wouldn't want to say
the weirdest enemy you've seen.
I don't know.
I think you'd have to go through my lace
but I was pretty simple
that we did that last week
or it was pretty some
on there that I liked.
Have you ever watched an anime or a show?
And you're just like
what the did I just watch
that made zero sense to me?
Like kinda like, like not in like the vein
of like, you know, this was kind of thing
but like just genuinely the
storytelling was so like
on the same lines as
the ending of Angelique
or like a, you know, like
a take on concrete or so.
Yeah. I mean the first
time I watched van galleon
I was like, I don't,
what the I was like, Oh
that's how they're going to end it.
And like, you know
some people love finding
the deeper meaning in that.
And I'm just like, that was a bit.
I'm just gonna get on with my life.
I just that's really concerned me.
I just
But I, I don't.
And then like maybe a
video of my recommended
Monkey bar activation.
Yeah. I
Think I've like programmed
my brain to like
just make my life easier.
So like when I want to just,
you know, stuff like that
but might drive some people mad.
I'm just like monkey forget monkey Buffon.
I just find it funny.
How like, considering like
Previous episode
you said like how you love to
challenge yourself every day.
You definitely do not like to
challenge yourself on anime
but like more, what is
What is thinking about the end
of Ethan galleon
challenging year in any way?
How was that?
Well, not necessarily in
a Vivo, but like, you know
something like, you
know, like a fully Coolio
like a take on King Cree where it's like
there are deeper meanings behind
here's the thing where you watch it once
and you can't get everything you
you can't enjoy from just
like watching it one.
Yeah. But like, why
would that challenge you?
There
Is all in challenge as
in like, it makes you
You think about its themes more
and kind of challenges your
I guess like perception of
how you like consume it.
I guess it's hard to describe
It. It, it challenged challenges.
. It's like, I broke them.
I've watched those things where it's
like the deeper meaning
everything more often than not.
Like I realized that that
that's what they're doing.
And I'm like, Oh, okay, cool.
And then I'll just, I'll let
go on Google and I'll be like,
what were they trying to say?
But like, don't you
like? Cause I find
Like some enjoyment in kind of watching it
and trying to figure it out myself.
You know what I mean?
I got a good way to, it's
like unraveling a puzzle
by yourself and it's like
playing a puzzle game.
Right. You're given
the pieces and you know
you're not told what the
right answer is, but it's
up to you and it's up to
you to unravel it yourself.
It's more like, it's more
like you've given a bunch
of pieces and as you're
playing around with the pieces
you realize that it's a
puzzle that can't be solved.
This is like, I love map.
Right. Because there is a problem
and it is always very clearly
defined as such, right.
It's not logical with like yeah.
With stories and all that kind of stuff.
It's I don't like that.
I have to figure out what
this guy was thinking about.
Like sometimes I might
get a meaning that is not
even remotely close to
what he was thinking
or the author was thinking when
they were writing the thing
down. And to me, that
bothers me that I can just
wildly get the answer wrong
and I'll never be corrected.
I like that.
But you assume that that
there's a right answer.
Well, what if he didn't know
there was a right answer
And that's the problem is
that I don't like that when
there's just like an
interpretation and it's like
you just make up what you want.
And then it's like, then
What? I would argue that
The story can still
entertain you in that aspect
whether it is the actual
correct answer or not
Like, think about it much, I guess.
That's I just, I watch it and
I, I like whatever thoughts
I have when I finish.
I'm like, all right, cool.
Yeah. That's what I'm going to leave with.
And most of the time, I
don't really care to try
and find the meaning in it.
And so I think, again
I know this is like,
that's such monkey brain.
You can't appreciate
Final, et cetera, et cetera.
But I'd say that's even more
normal at the end of the day.
I just don't care.
I think people like
Me who like actually like trying
to find the deeper meaning.
I think we're the minority.
Yeah. I think I'm the
minority here because I talk
about the reason I value this so much is
because there has been
time where like a piece
of media has literally affected
sometimes the way I think
or the way I view life.
So, because I know it
can have that effect.
I, you know, I try to search
it out whenever I can.
Whenever I find that there
might be even a glimpse
that there might be a deeper
meaning I love going into it.
No, I just like, I like
everything to be efficient.
I like everything to be done.
Everything on a silver platter, right?
No, no, not at all.
I like it when things are
very clearly defined the rules
like this is why, like,
I always, like I never
ever did any artistic
subjects in school, right?
Yeah. I don't like how it's all
it's all like a mess and
it's totally interpretation.
Yeah. I like how
in math and physics and life,
the rules, they make sense.
And you can, you can like
take them in and you can like
No, I get like, you know
my math and physics were my favorite tool.
Not fun when I'm like
reading a book or something
and I'm doing this and I'm,
I'm just being presented
with a bunch
of nonsense that I'm after
to make sense of myself
Argue then that if it's
a bunch of nonsense
without an interpretation,
then that's just a bad story
Sometimes. Yeah.
I mean, sometimes you can make your own
you can make your own thoughts
up from what I was being presented to you.
I want you to just kind of like
cool. Alright, nice.
I came up with what I think happened
and then it's like, all right,
well that's what I think.
I get that like the best
stories are the ones where
you can read it.
Like someone like you
can read it where like
you don't have to even
think about the fact
that there might possibly
be a deeper meaning
and it's still enjoyable.
And at the same time, people
like me that liked to look
for deeper meanings can also enjoy it.
Yeah. Like once you get too
philosophical, but you know, why
why do we watch entertainment
is to feel things
that's the end all be all right.
Entertainment to make us
feel something, whatever you
want to feel, whether
it's like adrenaline.
Sometimes you just want to
feel depressed or whatever
you know, it's and watching
something like, for example
the ending episode of
the van galleon I've I
remember first time I've watched it.
I hated that because I'm just like, why
why can I not just be given the answer?
Why, why is the answer?
Not just, you know, being presented to me
on like a golden platter, you
know, that's what I wanted.
And then as I grew older
and I, it stuck with me
and I've re watched it
and I'm just like, Oh, this
is, this is making me feel
Different things.
Maybe I'll change my mind on it.
But right now for me
like entertainment and
media, it's just like
I just want to relax and
thinking is not relaxing.
I just want to get on with it.
Cause I'm so God much.
And I just want to do
the things I want to do.
And to me and payment is purely
like a gas stop on my destination.
It's like, let's just stop for
a moment and have some fun.
I don't know.
No, I mean, I get that too.
Like, it's not like every pieces came
and I watched this like mind
bending and it's like, it's
like I said, sometimes you just need to be
in a very specific room to
enjoy this piece of media.
I'm just like, you know what?
I want to feel pretentious right now.
Like I kind of want to like figure
out if this has a deeper meaning.
Like I, I, when I speak to people who talk
like that about the media,
they like, I'm like, you know
part of me is envious because
I don't care for that.
But because I think a lot of
people are envious of that
because I think when you meet
a lot of people, they'll claim
that they can see the, find
a meaning and all of that.
And most of the time
they have no idea, but
you know, I dunno, I'm
just completely open
with the fact that I'm
like, well, I don't care.
I don't care to care
Yeah. What I like
What, what I don't understand
is the other extreme
where it's people who
can't seem to enjoy media
unless there is something deeper about it.
Like, I, there are times
when I just want to
watch a shitty ISA call
and just not have to think,
you know what I mean?
Yeah. I guess it's like
the people who like think
that every single piece of entertainment
or media has some kind of
deeper meaning under it.
You know what I mean?
It's like no anime review.
A non non-binary has no deeper meaning.
It's just a slice of life.
Like just chill.
Well, it feels like privilege.
The problem it's like my only
problem is life in life is
that my media that I
consume doesn't have enough
Meaningless. It's like, it's
like, Oh my how privileged
I used to be where that's a
concern, you know what I mean?
Like
That's like the biggest,
first world problem where like
you can't get enough fine
art, you know what I mean?
That's like literally
like billionaire problem.
Oh, what me off even more.
It's like, you can have your
own interpretation for media
right? That's, that's, that's
very normal for everything.
But what me
off is when people
project their own meaning
onto this piece of media.
Like I remember, I remember
where the attack on Titan, when
you know, the basement
thing happened to them.
There were articles to be like, Oh yeah
this is promoting Nazi-ism
and stuff like that.
And I'm just like, Oh, it's
not, Oh God, he gets, he gets
to a point where there's a
difference between, you know
analyzing it and interpreting
it in your own way.
And just there's even when
they know the right answer as
well. Right.
It's just like, no, no, I don't
care what the author says.
This is what it actually means.
He just doesn't know.
It's like, no, I'm pretty sure
if the author said that
this is what it means.
That's what a mean.
Well, it's, I mean, there's
plenty of cases of where like
The author loses control over the work.
Well, I mean, isn't that like
the whole thing was Ava, right?
Where like the frog grip,
the death of the author.
So you've always been up to
anything interesting recently.
I mean, we're currently
back in lockdown always.
So we haven't really been
able to do much really
Japanese covers pretty useless.
I mean, yeah, but
Statement restaurant,
please close at eight.
So you can still travel
and do whatever you want.
But you know
Not an enforced lockdown in Japan.
It's always a suggestion.
It's a suggestion that
in Japan people listen.
Yeah, yeah, no, I was crazy.
I think like where was it?
It was like, it was
because usually after we
finished recording a podcast
we going out to dinner
and stuff like that.
And I think we were at like
one of the restaurants nearby
and they were playing like news
footage and the re watched.
Yes. There was a shot of station
zero people in front of it, which is
like crazy because she did
a go station for you guys.
I know it was like literally
the most busy station I think
in the world.
Isn't it?
Yeah. Yeah.
It is.
Yeah. It is at least in Japan.
Most of the world.
I think station.
I died a little inside.
Whenever someone, whenever
a friend comes to Japan
I asked where to meet and
they say Shinji meeting
at re watched station is
impossible, but like navigating it.
Isn't so bad now I hate now.
I think you get Bouguereau
is worse than average.
Oh no.
What are you on?
Because when you try and
get to like the other
like the subway lines, you'd
like for someone she can stay
she literally has like 30
exits girl has maybe like 10
like depending on which exit
you come out of sh sh re watched
like it tells you to go on
the other side of the station.
And you would think walking
in a straight line would work.
No, you can't walk in a straight line
in re watched because
you've got to pass depending
on where you're on a
station, you've got to pass
through like 10 different dailies
with gigabit grow station.
I always, if someone's just like meet
at this gate that I dunno where the it is
then I'll just go out of the regular gate
and I can at least walk
around the station.
But if you try
and do that with re
watched station, you're.
If you ever come to Japan
and you're going to meet anyone here
and you're staying and
you're staying there
re watched never say you're going to meet
meet at re watched station.
It is a lie.
Okay.
It's saying you're going to
meet the re watched station is
like saying you're going to meet somewhere
in like times square or something.
It's a massive area and
station doesn't do that.
It's not even that it's like saying like
I'll meet you in New York.
It's like, all right, cool place outside
of the station and then
send them the Google.
Yeah. Yeah.
But you could do that
with any other station.
It'd be way easier to get out of it.
Cause I, I remember I
I met Jeff here mother's
basement at re watched station.
And as soon as he said it,
I was like, Oh, here we go.
God, I got to find, it's
basically finding where's Wally
with your mates.
And you know, with Jeff,
is it shouldn't be hard
cause he's massive.
Right. And he says, he,
I asked him where he is
and he's he goes, Oh,
I'm a near this place.
I think it's, it looks like
there's a big camera nearby.
I'm like, cool, cool.
So, so I go to like the
nearest big camera and so
big camera is like this
it's huge department
store Charlotte.
It's like electronic store basically.
So I go to the IU West re
watched B camera, and then
I send him the message and
I'm just like, okay, I'm
outside big camera.
And he goes, I don't
see you and I'm go buck.
It was that at that point
I knew ticks off of one.
I up.
And I, and I, and I tell him
just to send me the Google map
coordinates and he's
on the other side of
the, is that re watched
West, like Google maps.
It's so much easier.
Oh. So you can just literally meet
at like one station
on. Yeah.
Because some of the stations lie
with how to get places
like as well has like a
East West exit or something.
No, dude re watched is
like, has like seven West.
It has an East West exit.
Yeah. That doesn't, it doesn't
even like re watched doesn't
even have an East West exit.
I think Shinju has like an East West exit
and a new east-west exit.
That's how many exits
their own re watched that
they've literally run out of
directions to name the exits
The train stations in Wales
where it's just a platform.
What was it?
That was the whole station,
maybe a vending machine.
If you're lucky
Honestly like what I
usually do, I've done this
with a few people and
it's actually proven to
be effective is that instead
of meeting in re watched
you meet one station down
on the, which is Yogi.
Because walking, because
walking to your Yogi, like
from your yoga to re watched
is the exact same time
that it will take to actually get
out of re watched station
is because walking
from one side of the station
to another, depending
on where you are could take
up to 15 to 20 minutes.
Whereas like Yogi only has two
exits, very straightforward.
No, bro, what do you mean?
I'm doing what you love to do best?
Which is min maxing myself.
Okay. Well what is the optimal straddling?
Right?
Google has this thing
now where it tells you
which cart to get on.
So it tells you which train car to get
on for the smoothest and quickest
exit and 95% of the time.
It's spot on.
Let's do that.
I'll say trick question though.
There is no smooth exit or re watched.
There is, there is never
I have legit.
Like I always have to Goshen.
Juki right.
And obviously I'm always using
to do that because I need to
and I listened to what Google, my God
Google tells me, you know,
every time and it bang on
it's like go this exit gob, the first set
of stairs you see every single
time it's basically right.
You think someone who just
come to came to Japan ball
like which direction of re
watched and which ex there are.
I don't even know where it, I get out.
I, I mean, it works for me.
I just listened to what the PC,
the PC master race tells me.
If the computers tell me to go somewhere
I go where the computer second
Carnivores.
The first time you come
to Japan, don't do that.
Find where you want to go.
When you go to the station,
there'll be numbers
on the floor.
Just pick the number
what the Google tells
you to go on and then do
it. Trust
re watched. You all get lost
navigating this station.
Yeah. Don't don't trust the station signs.
Cause there'll be like, Oh
yeah, if you're on the platform
be like the exit this way
You don't trust the sessions.
That's all I've got.
Because, because when you go
to re watched and you
follow Google maps, right?
Google maps says, take the
West exit out of re watched.
And then you go, you go to,
you, go out your trailer
you go see the signs.
And there is probably every exit.
But the exit that it says on Google maps
The mistake, you're looking
at the signs, right?
The signs, the signs,
all they do is deceive.
They, they make you second guess.
Right? Don't listen to the song full of.
Listen to what Google says.
A hundred percent, right?
Because thing is right.
You'll be on the platform.
Right? And there'll be like eight sets
of stairs that you can take.
That'll be an hour.
This is like this way.
This is the way to where you want to go.
And sometimes it's like the
most unoptimized way to get
out of the out of the station
or go to the line that you want to go.
And there's bunch of stairs.
And sometimes it isn't
clear which stairs to get.
It's a mess.
Right? If Google tells
you to get off at a cart
go immediately to the nearest
set of stairs that you see it.
I guarantee it'll work.
And just go out the exit
that you see closest.
It'll always work.
Google knows.
Don't listen to the signs.
They're lie back.
Don't try a voice.
You'll see.
I dunno, man.
I, I think I'll just
avoid getting off fishing.
I just, I just feel
like not going through re watched
is just the optimal straps.
I'm just, I want to fly
out of the country without an airport.
It's like, if you're going to go to Japan
you're going to be going
through re watched.
Yeah.
Yeah. But like I rather
meet like somewhere far
away from the actual
Station out of this place to meet
Somewhere, anywhere near the station
because it's just extra.
It's just extra stress.
You're adding onto your commute.
AI. Do it for you.
I don't know because it
I have tried following
the AI and Google maps.
Isn't perfect.
That's pretty good.
Is this, what is this why you hate it
Mo more because of the AI maps?
I definitely.
So that's why you hate you
Such a mess of a station.
The way it's been laid out.
Like shouldn't you queue.
I get it.
It makes sense.
is that the science makes sense.
You can see the
I follow assigned to an exit.
It actually takes me to the eggs.
Like, because I like putting my trust
in my own sense of direction.
Right. So if I'm in a
place like eco bucardo
I can trust that wherever I am.
I can find the right way out.
I just follow the signs.
Not the right way with, with, with
re watched. I'm if you
literally have to put your trust
in an AI machine to tell
you the right direction
then it is just a poorly planned system.
I mean
It works though.
I kept where I need to get to no problem.
Well, let's say that I wanted
to people watching this
you'd never been to Japan.
Like what the is this problem?
If you've never been to
Japan, don't listen to corner
meet anywhere outside of China
Listen to the white guy in Germany.
Would you trust the white guy?
Listen, listen to me,
the white guy, trust me.
I find life hacks where they don't exist.
Yeah. I mean, we've locked down.
There's not so much new I can be doing.
So recently I had, this
had woke up one day
and I was just like, Oh, I
should get back into fate.
Go. No, no, I saw you taking a bath.
And I was just like, no, no, no
No. It's like watching.
It's like watching a
friend start a new drug.
You know what I mean?
It's no, please stop.
It's just seeing a mate
like just relapsed.
And he's like, no, no, you
were 10 weeks sober, man.
Come on.
I mean
I'm kind of the same way.
Like I
I did something that I
haven't done in literal years
which is by an arrogance,
like a Japanese area.
Ooh. I am brand new
Came out arrogant.
So cause I was in Akihabara a
while back doing some shopping
for a video and, and I was
walking parceling Mellon books
which is like, you know,
where they sold a little
like donations and
stuff and out the front.
Okay. So basically say out the
front, they have like a bunch
of signs for like new games
that come out and every now
and then they'll also show
some signs for like arrogance.
Right. Cause that's where they sell it.
And there was one where I was just like
that actually looks really cool.
Like I didn't actually
know it was an arrogant.
I thought it was like a
standard JPG or whatever
but I was like, that
actually kind of looks cool.
So I looked it up, found out
it's an arrogant by Alice soft.
And I was like, wow,
Alice self actually just
like click baited me into
thinking that this was
like a legitimate JL Fiji
when it's just a irrigate
with JPG elements in it.
So I was like, all right, you know what?
I'll buy it.
It's locked
down. I
Go out anywhere and I haven't bought
and played an arrogance so many years.
it.
I'll do it.
Play at it.
And that's kind of all I've
been doing for the past three
Days. Really trying to
give context to kind corner
About what Alice soft has done.
Yeah. I just zoned out.
I don't know if there's
any games like that
of famous outside of Japan.
That also basically Alice
soft is like one of the oldest
I guess like most well-known
in the era gay world.
There's like illusion
like Alice soft, what?
A leaf,
a leaf?
Yeah. You train them and poke them on
You know, Maples and other maker.
My favorite Pokemon type maple
lumber sugar is another one.
There's like
Basically it's like, it's
it's basically just like
an O G arrogant developer.
And they came up
with a new game that
looks completely different
to anything that they've done.
Okay. So I played a few like
Ali soft games back in my head.
So we said, what the do you do in America?
Explain to me it's a visual novel
visual novel with porn.
Or if it's good
Connors like, wait, how can you get
off? How
Does that work?
If it's good.
Basically think of it as
it's like perfectly halfway
between jacking off to a Dogan
and jacking off to a hammer.
Imagine how the latter
or the former field site
Basically it's like jacking
off to a dojo, but the audio
from the hand ties playing.
Okay.
Yeah. So there's voice acting
Sound effects.
So, that can also be auto played
or so like you you're
playing this story game
and you might say you just beat one
out and then you just carry
on. Yeah.
(laughing)
I that
You know, 30 seconds after I've got it.
I've just looked at discussed
of what I've been testing.
I'm like, turn that off
With all the milk you've been watching.
I will be disgusted right after it.
You are in like a heightened
state of like, you're
you're basically like a monk
for 30 seconds where you're
like, I will never have sex.
Well, I'm not, I don't know
why I'm like turning the.
You get postnatal.
Oh, a hundred percent
every time, every time.
And then I'm like, weak-willed with porn.
If I could abandon porn, I
would, you know what I mean?
Yeah. I would.
If I, if every guy says that
if you could say comment, yeah.
You just never need to ever again.
I'll be like, sure.
Why not?
Well, let's try it.
Let's see how it goes.
I have the completed.
No, not November.
No. I've never attempted it.
Well, it sounds like you're
wanting to attempt to right now
I ended up getting like
a wet dream eventually.
Right? Like that'll happen.
Right. If you don't care.
Well, if you leave it for a month, yeah.
When was the last time you
didn't check off for a month?
I will never, but that's because I'm
but that's because I'm not going to
Spew being like, I can live without point.
Like
No, I want a one point.
No, I want to, I want to live without it.
I don't want to be, I
just find out this is
this is the literally I
don't want to be horny.
I want to, like I've
ever seen in real life.
I hate being distracted
from what I'm trying to do.
And it's just distracting.
I look at that meme and I'm
just like, I want both really.
I want to be horny and happy.
So you just, you just say you see this
as like a distraction
from your optimized life.
Optimized lifestyle is
being ruined by this.
Oh my God.
I can never hear the word
optimized the same way
after this podcast.
You're you're playing this game.
You know, it's a game.
How are we going to game?
It's reading.
It's tricking you in a jacket.
Alice soft one has like full
on JPG RPG elements as well.
Oh. So you're like you're in the middle
of a battle and you're trying to Jack
off. No, no
No, no.
Okay. So think of, okay, this is
I hate the fact that I'm
using this as an example.
Think of
Oh no.
Oh God, here we go.
Wait. Like the persona
games are, in my opinion
persona games are the
perfect blend of visual novel
and JPG way.
Like they've somehow managed
to make two like elements
of two completely
different styles of games
and mix it perfectly.
Right. So in persona, the J
RPG elements are most often
than not completely separated
from the actual visual novel elements.
Right. In persona.
Yeah. In persona.
Whereas
What a visual novel of quake.
I dunno if I just fell
small, smaller Jake.
No, that's pretty this for me
Man.
So in persona, right?
Like the, you have the
visual novel elements
and then you have the
JLL in between the yeah.
Yeah. So like, you know,
you'd have like, you go
through a dungeon or whatever,
and then, you know, once
once you complete that dungeon
then it goes into the visual.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You call it.
I mean, I would argue that
the GRPC elements fill
up for you as well, but regardless.
Right.
So, you know, you have
like the story elements
and you have like the actual
like gameplay elements.
Right. Whereas in this era gay
the sex scenes time start to happen
during only the visual novel elements.
Hmm. Okay.
So, so the, the vision of elements
of the sex scenes and the
gameplay stuff breaks up that.
So like a standard Silicon.
So like the standard error,
like a standard error.
Okay. That doesn't have
JFE GL in the heart
it's basically just a visual novel
with sex scenes put into it.
Yeah. Right.
So it kind of interweaves
with the story with this one.
It's just that separately.
It has a J Apigee portion as well.
Wait, what do you mean?
Like you battle, like what are you doing?
Like what?
I'm confused, what are you doing?
What the else do you do in a J LPG?
So you're just, it's just a
dead and normal J RPG game
where you're going around
battling monsters leveling off.
And then it cuts to like
a visual novel with yeah.
Who comes up with
Unlike on a slide.
I can literally hear the gears
like turning in his head
and it's just not computing.
It's just like, wait, what?
No. Like they don't, they're
not coming to the gym.
They're just stuck.
Right?
Yeah. I'm just like,
this sounds to me, right.
This is the equivalent of
being like, so it's a food
tray that jacks you off.
It's like, I don't want
those two things going
near each other.
What are you talking about?
Like those two elements,
the JL PG game, and then
just a visual novel with porn in it.
I like just two elements
that just shouldn't be
involved at all.
Why not?
Why? Why would, why wouldn't you want them
Look, don't look like your
As if like there's the visual novel
like storytelling, part, and
then there's the sex scene.
And then immediately, and then
immediately there's a battle.
That's not how it works
But how does it work then?
It
Works as if like there's
the storytelling element
the visual novel element.
And in the middle, there is a sex scene.
So it's sandwiched between
the visual novel elements.
Okay.
So there's the visual novel elements where
they're telling a story and there's porn
in the middle and then
it just cuts to when it
when the done with the talking it goes
to a normal dead-ass game.
Yeah. What, why
Does this look good to you?
Am I insane?
This sounds awful.
It sounds great.
No, it doesn't.
You're just playing devil's advocate.
Okay. I've I mean, I've, I, I say this
to someone who has also played Aero gaze
before this there's
something, there's something
about like hen Thai games
and arrow gays, where
the sex scenes feel like this
there's something different
about feeling like
you've earned a sex scene
Oh fuck off.
A hundred percent, a
hundred percent agree.
It is.
It is
Like you could have the
most mediocre sex scene
but you feel
like you've earned that sex scene.
And it's even more so in this game
because like you can unlock
certain sex scenes depending
on what you do in the J RPG
a person who watches a hand-tight.
I don't want an X-Box achievement.
I want a hand tie.
And you know what?
I'm a person
Who watches a hint high and skip straight
to 15 or 20 minutes or not
know what we're talking about.
Story and hand tag.
But I don't want to sit there
and read a book and then
into the book and then
wipe the cut off my hand
and go around my RPG world,
leveling up my character.
Right. I don't wanna fucking deal with
like, look, don't get me wrong.
Like
I'll say, man, this is not
the type of game for anybody.
This isn't, this isn't, this isn't like.
I completely understand that.
The stuff I like in hindsight
It's pretty shit.
Yeah. This is like, you
don't want to say like
don't eat where you shit.
Right. This is like beating
the that you're sleeping.
Like this is like, this is so fucked.
Like this shouldn't be
a combination of things.
Like only Japan would make something
like this because it's
just so stupidly like
like this shouldn't exist.
Like look at honeypot.
That was, that was made by Americans.
I don't like honeypot by honey pot either.
I enjoy honeypot because it's
literally what I just think
of because I can buy American
because like, I, for example
Bejeweled or some wasn't that game.
Like it was one of those
I was like, it's like a puzzle game.
It's a puzzle game.
But also gave him that a too.
But then under, because
the thing is, the thing
is it's like Jackie off
to a jigsaw puzzle, be
Like, Oh, Oh, it's making porn.
The pieces
Of making a poem because the
thing is, the thing is right.
You have this gameplay loop, right?
You have this gameplay loop,
but unlike you, I need a reward
for playing this game.
I need a reward for playing this game.
Unlike you.
I don't the X-Box
I don't jack off to Xbox
achievements, either terrible.
Most of the time, it has to
be story most of the time.
That's why I play games.
If I have a gameplay loop,
you can have the best
gameplay loop of all time.
If there's no motivation for
me to play it, then I'm just
going to not play most games
that don't have a story.
Cause it's like, what's the
why, why am I playing this?
Yeah. There's there are so
many games that I agree have
I can totally agree with that
but why is that porn in it?
Because that's the rewards
you get for playing
The game because I'm sorry you
find feeling a little horny.
Sometimes I just can't
imagine holding the yet
Xbox controller and then just put it down
get the tissue box out like what?
Say for example, like a game, like
for example, degeneracy
should not be reached
Well at first I gave him like
dead cells, which I heard
which I, which I played
and I played it for what
five minutes.
And I thought this was a really good game.
And then I got bored for five
minutes because I was like
why am I playing this game?
There's no motivation
for you to actually play
through levels.
It's nice gameplay loop.
Same with something like Celeste.
That's amazing game.
This is an amazing game.
I went through one level when I got bored
because I really couldn't
care about the story, man.
It's so good.
That's the thing.
If it had a reward
for me to complete the
level that I would inflate
through it, then there needs
to be some kind of work.
So what Guk is saying, is
that Celeste would've been
And what's the last, would it be?
every time.
If, every time, like if every
time I completed a level
of Celeste, there was a Hentai scene
or something like that.
You literally just went
Like, Guk wants to S to
have like a beat a level.
And then the porn hub
music starts playing.
That's what Guk wants.
Yes. That's I want that.
Imagine guys are too
comfortable jacking off.
Imagine that imagine an
Sero gay with something
on the gameplay level
of dead cells or Celeste
or something along those lines,
masterpiece, masterpiece.
I'm just imagining that right now.
That would be, that would be a mask.
That will be amazing.
Because like, you know,
every time you finish a level
of Celeste you have such light.
Yes. Like moments, right?
It's like, yes.
I, I went through that.
I died hundreds and hundreds of times.
And now here is my reward.
Hell yes?
That is going to be the best
jack off you'll ever have.
Yeah. To, to not saying,
make Celeste porn.
I'm not saying that's what I'm saying.
For example, we don't want
to lude the character.
That's not, we're talking
about, we're talking about
if we had a gameplay loop
of something like Celeste
or something on that level.
And then we had, we
had it hen side, my God
that is improving upon perfection.
You people have not
how has noon crowdfund
the now I'm making these
I amazed all the.
I am going to fund some money.
Gimme Some money
I'll make it happen.
It's fucking animals like you
have the reason why we have
like Minecraft sex scenes.
Like this is the prop
you guys would want to
put porn and everything.
Oh, have you seen the
Minecraft porn on YouTube?
It's so fucking awful.
Some of us kind of like
finishes at level in mind.
That's not even a levels in mind.
Jerry finishes getting
some diamonds in Minecraft
just swapped over
to the next tab and
start playing Minecraft.
Do you know how hard it is
to get diamonds in Minecraft?
That's like a great achievement.
I can say that publicly
because I know I'm not the
only one who genuinely thinks
that the fact that Minecraft
won't even exists means
that I am not.
You're saying you like Minecraft porn.
No, I'm not have a problem with it.
No, I mean, I don't care what this is.
It's like a kid's game though.
I've this, this podcast
has been a weird one.
I just think it's sad, right?
That there are kids out
there who legitimately like
are curious about porn.
And the first thing they think is my two
loves Stephen Minecraft.
I would like to see if
they did that to him.
Cause it's only kids
watching these things.
Right? Cause no adult can to Steve.
Steve blocks something.
You know?
I mean, no joke.
I'm not saying I am,
but I think, I think you
underestimate some like adults willpower.
I've okay.
I have jacked off to Minecraft.
No, no.
I've this is the first I've
ever heard of Minecraft porn
on this.
You've never seen it.
Never seen it.
Describe it to me please.
I mean, we just kind of
have to show you this.
You need to describe it to me
In like four or five years ago
wishing been made the video about it
but there was actually
like so much like full
on traditional porno
I've made in Minecraft.
When, when you first
mentioned it, I thought, okay
we're just being sarcastic.
I know.
There's like a, what's his name?
Captain sparkles.
Right? The one who was
like Minecraft animations.
Yeah. Basically imagine that.
But they would literally be
like a porno situation where it was like
someone would be like, Oh
no, it's like a, high-quality
like Minecraft I saw one
that was like, Steve, like
like Steve, like a creeper
or something or something.
And the creeper is like.
All right.
Yeah. This is legit.
This is actually, we will show you.
This is the path.
If you don't hold back, right.
If you let your creative juices run wild
on projects like Joey wants to do
with all of this, this is what happens.
And we don't need this.
We don't need this.
I don't know.
Don't get me wrong.
We don't need it.
That's the thing.
Right? People want it?
No, no, no.
It doesn't matter what people
want people to have to sell
People don't deserve what they want.
I don't know if it's worth,
I don't know if it's worse.
What I just imagined in my
mind from you describing it
or actually watching the actual thing
we'll show you afterwards.
And I don't know, maybe
just we can add a clip
of like got reacting to when
we're done with the episode
we'll leave the cameras rolling.
Just like this is a post, right?
It's literally like, it can
only be kids watching it.
Right. It's so disturbing
That it's just funny.
Well, I mean, it's
Funny to us, but obviously I'm sure.
I'm sure the on the kid
watching is pretty much
every reached that age.
Is this what our parents felt
when they walked in and saw us
like jacking and elf to
animated he's how is this how
they felt now?
I mean, I'll never forget the look.
My parents gave me.
Whoa. You've never had like
your parents like walking
on you jacking off.
No, I've hit it very well.
If they have really, again, I
remember that was my stairs.
Would Creek I had a warning.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Your parents walked in
on you with my dad walked in
on me once.
How big was the screen?
I was like this tiny meant
jacking off on like a game boy SP
Like my old, like desktop
computer with like
I don't think it was like
a 16 inch or whatever.
I had a black and white TV.
Oh really?
Yeah.
The black and white.
It's like a hand me down
and it can fly like via.
Yeah. It's awful.
So I couldn't couldn't put porn in it.
All right.
Well, I can't believe I'm
about to tell this story.
Oh God.
I don't even remember how old I was.
It was easy.
It was, it was, I remember,
I don't remember exactly
how old it was, but it was
around that age as a teenager.
When you first discovered porn, right?
Like, you know, way between like.
I don't know, 13 to 15,
something like that.
Maybe even early for some people.
I don't know.
But I remember a lot.
It was, I think it was
legitimately the first time
I watched like a hentai on my computer and
Straight to hentai even watch it.
This was like, this is like
not long after I discovered porn.
He quickly
Got down that rabbit hole.
Yeah, no like that, that first time I
but the first time with
hentai was a different story
And I was in my room and
like, my room has like
had a lock on it.
So I thought I locked the door.
Oh, Oh.
And my thought.
And I remember, I remember
as well, we hentai it was
it was a comedy show,
Collegeville, Kalamazoo.
Oh, classic classic.
Right. It's like next
to bible black classic.
Right. And, and yeah.
So I was like, Oh,
something has arosen in me.
(laughing)
right. My, my little joke
Has woken up.
Right. So I was like, let's give it a go.
And so I did it and then
I hear like a, a clock.
Oh yeah.
The door opening.
And I had looked around and
Standing there.
He's pretty, he's pretty
proud of you there.
No, no.
Oh. He looked at me and
he looked at what was
on my screen and he looked
at me again and he just said
Really, mate?
- Your dad seems like the
most Australian man alive.
He just said, I remember
exactly what he said.
He's like really mate couldn't
have been regular porn?
He was like
I wouldn't be, I wouldn't
even be disappointed with you
if it was just regular porn.
And I was like, I mean, I've,
I've been past that point.
I was kind of experimenting.
And he's like, all right, whatever.
Like, I dunno what I dunno.
I have already gotten
bored of regular porn.
I'm seeking new adventures.
I could, I could legitimately
see the very moment
Where the disappointment came.
You know what I mean?
It's like, it's like,
it's like a certain look
in my dad's eyes where it
kinda went from like, Whoa
what are you doing to, oh.
- Oh no, he's into that.
He's into that shit.
Huh? Oh yes, father.
I am into that.
Are you winning son?
- No.
He wasted his days.
And now I talk about it for a job.
So yeah.
I hope you're proud of me dad.
- That felt so desperate.
- Please love me please.
I'm winning now.
I'm finally winning dad.
- It's just that that
moment is carved into you.
And you're like, you're
like the son who just looks
for your dad's approval.
- I don't have a lot of
like distinct memories
during my childhood,
but that was definitely
one that will like forever stick with me.
Like I, it, it's kind of just
implanted itself into the back
of my brain now.
- I don't know.
I've never been caught,
jacking off at all because
to me it's like, if, if I do
this, a checklist happens.
- I think 100 for me, yeah.
- It's it's
It's, it's the same-
- When my snake, unfortunately,
- It's it's the same way, when you know,
you leave the house
and you have your okay.
Pat keys, wallet, phone, same thing.
Same thing.
When, when you do the same
thing, same thing, you know
you do, you do the deed and
you just like head door locks
headphones on or whatever.
Make sure nobody's in the
house or nobody can hear.
And then you start.
- With the lock on my door.
I got a little too overconfident.
So I'm like, yeah, this is
This is full proof isn't it?
And then I just, I guess
I just forgot, you know
what it felt like, it
felt like, you know, when
you're playing Pokemon
and you like go into a
cave and you put repel on
And it runs out just before, you're
about to leave the cave and
you get into an encounter.
That's what it felt like.
I was like shit, I wasn't
that close, but I don't know.
Like I've, like I said.
I thought getting walked in on, right?
- Yeah.
- Is like a common thing.
Cause you see it so much on the internet.
Right? It's like, I go
in like, what do I do?
Like, you know, that kind of stuff.
So have you ever walked in on
anyone or been walked in on?
- Oh my God. Maybe I have, I don't know.
I feel like these are
like buried memories.
Yeah. That's pretty a good chance.
I've pretty walked down.
I dunno.
I've been to parties and seen shit
but like people to don't
care, but just like
like a private time, you know?
No, I don't think I have actually no.
- Yeah. I, I th I think I've
never walked in on someone
but the closest I've come
is it was union university.
You know, it was visiting
a mate and it was
like a group house.
So like two or three
of them mates are there
and we were getting
ready for the night out.
So I was just like
saying hello to everyone.
And then I knocked on this.
I knock on one of my
mates door and I, you know
that panic scramble hear?
(laughing)
You can hear so there's doors locked.
Right. But I knock on the
door and all I heard was
Honestly, that's all I heard was.
(scrambling noise)
And then he opens the door
and the laptop, which is opposites
like where the door is,
is conveniently closed.
So I'm just like, Oh, you're just doing.
And he was like, nothing.
I was just, just working on
my presentation, you know
But I've never actually
walked in on anyone
but I feel like it's more common
in America because in university there
if you share a room that's,
this is what I can imagine.
Weird to me.
This is why I can't
imagine having a roommate
because how would you,
how'd you schedule that?
Do do anyone in America.
Can you ask me, do you have
do you actually have to
schedule your sessions?
Because when do you have to
be like, where are you going?
How long will you be out what
time are you coming back?
Urban legend.
Where do you tell each other?
Where do you like to do you like
have like a calendar
where you schedule it?
Okay guys.
Okay. So this time is my time.
There's going to be a sock on the door.
That's how you know.
And if the sock is on the
door, then it is like code red.
Don't come in.
Never disturbing during
I mean, like, I guess like
I want to ask you guys is like, I mean, we
none of us have children.
Right. But like, hypothetically
say it like bright.
Right, right, right, right up
Hypothetically. Right.
Like if you ever like,
get a kid, for example
and you become the role of the parent
and then you walked in on
your kid doing that, like
how would you guys, like, what
would you say, join it after?
I don't know.
This is not, it's not really
to have a conversation there.
You're like, sit down son.
It's like, Whoa, but I'm sure
some parents have, right.
It's like, Oh my God.
I don't know.
Like, what is even like as a parent
what's the correct answer.
Ah, I'm going to tell him not to do it.
Really. It really, because
they're going to do it anyway
but you don't encourage them and be like
watch as much porn as you want son.
I feel like my dad said that.
- What?
- Something similar.
He's just like, because
like I specifically
remember you can get addicted to porn.
Right, right, right.
I remember my dad wasn't
so much like disappointed
in the fact that I was
like jacking off it.
Okay. That was the Hentai
It was the hentai
He was like, I don't care
that you're jacking off.
Like if you have a penis
and you're an adult, that's normal.
Right. So whatever you were
eventually going to get
to this point
it could have been anything
else you were jacking off to.
I probably, you just walk out.
And then the next time I see like my child
I probably just be like, we
can just forget about it.
Right. Because I, I feel like
the more you talk about it
the more you put lights on it
the worst that they're going to feel.
Well, just, just make
it as, make it as casual
as possible to be like,
how many parents, you know
end up doing like this, sit down, son.
Let's have a talk.
I feel that's the worst answer.
You know what I mean?
Cause like, I feel like
there's nothing more.
I mean, I never got the talk
from my parents, but I feel
if I ever was in that
position, I'd be like.
Did you ever ask your parents
where babies came from?
You gave me some answer.
I still remember.
I still remember the answer my mind.
Yes. So I thought that
was literally what she
said was babies came
out of the belly button.
Right. And thinking about
this as an adult, I think I'm
that's permanently scarred me
because when I see a belly button now
cause as a kid, as a kid, I
had this disgusting thoughts
of oh babies crawl out there.
And now as a fully grown adult,
I still see belly button.
I'm just like, Oh
all I all I can think seen an ACE Ventura
You know, when he's coming
out of the Lake rhino,
that's all I can imagine.
It's like some alien shoes
like looking back I'd rather than my mom.
How just tell me graphically
where babies came
from. Well, as, as opposed
to just telling me yeah,
they, the belly button.
Cause I remember that.
I remember the first time, like there's
there's two moments that
have scarred me fluff.
One was that.
And the second time was the
first time I saw the matrix
where? Yeah, the matrix cause scene.
There's a scene where, how
have you guys seen the matrix?
Yeah. I can't imagine the scene.
So there's same thing.
I know.
Which one is it about?
Yeah, that there's a scene
where the agents pin Neo
down and then like a spidery
shrimp, like emergent
crawls up his belly button and that me
up so badly because I'm just like it.
Okay. I reinforced that it was possible
for things to go in or
out of the belly button.
So I'm just like protect
this at all costs.
my vital point.
I thought he was like some alien burst
our share where she's like, you know
I had a similar thing with
him, with the mummy, you know
when like the beetle is rolling.
That was the first time I
like physically was like
I'm sorry.
I feel like, yeah, that matrix thing.
I blocked out my mind
because I remember being
I remember watching
that like a ten-year-old
and being disgusted.
Yeah. God, it was awful.
But yeah.
I mean that's a tangent right from porn
I don't know if I'm my
kids or my kid do it.
Yeah. I'd probably be like,
well, did you do it efficiently?
Did you mean max and son?
How much time did you spend it?
But that 30 minutes you're in
that full that's way too long.
You cannot get in the
habit of doing that son.
I don't know.
Cause like when you see the
like people talking about like
I legit would worry if my kid
got like addicted to porn.
Oh it was like
you hear about the adults
who get addicted to porn.
Like Terry crews was addicted to porn.
Right? Was he?
Yeah, he was addicted to porn I think.
And there was generally
like I sent you the link.
So I, I was on YouTube
and there's just a video
something called, like
coming clean or something.
Remember it.
And it was just this guy
who was just like, no one
no one had exposed him on YouTube.
No one had said anything.
He just came out with it.
He was just like, I'm
addicted to porn guys.
I'm going broke because he's
like, Oh you had a few million.
And he just like
Oh yeah.
Oh, I do remember that.
He was that guy who was in
like a happy relationship.
He wasn't married.
Wasn't me happily married.
And
He wasn't, he wasn't like a
it was like a buff
really good-looking dude.
Yeah. I remember.
And he was just like, yes.
So like I'm just like
horribly addicted to porn.
Yeah. He just spent his money
on chatter Bay so bad for the dude.
And it's like, you know
had this like come out any other way.
People probably would've
mocked him, but he, you know
he spoke about it himself
and you kind of felt like
really bad for the dude.
You're like, I can't, I can't sympathize
per se because I would not sympathize.
I can't ex you know,
experience that myself.
But like, I was like, dude,
I would never want that
on like my kid or something to be like
cripplingly addicted to
like virtual video porn.
Right. Whatever.
I don't, I feel so bad about that.
I think it especially
hurts considering the fact
that like he's going broke.
Yeah. And luckily the guy like
the video is really good.
I recommend watching it.
Like just to like, I dunno.
And him and his wife was
like understanding of it.
And w she helped like walk him through it.
I still was really sweet
and I hope the guy's doing better now.
I've, I've no idea.
I didn't watch any of the videos, but like
how'd you even get to
a point when you rise?
Like what, what, what is
what is the line where you
realized, what, what is
what is a porn addiction?
You know?
It's, is it how snap it's
going to kill me for that joke?
It's like, is it to the
point where it's like
you're spending so much money that it's
like putting a dent on your
car to spend money on porn?
Yeah. You off.
I can handle the hot seat.
I've never spent any money on porn
I feel that is like a
big line to cross where
you're comfortable getting
your credit card out to
to put in.
Right. That's like just a lie.
I don't want to cross.
And I'd be really sad
in my son or my daughter,
if they were like
you've got a premium process subscription.
I'm like
why? Why?
Yeah. I don't know what it's
like to me spending money on
like Kensai games or something.
I completely understandable.
As soon as you spend money on
like, I guess real life porn
for some reason that just flips
a switch me to be like, how
why? I think it's because
Like, unlike arrogation like
hand-eye and stuff like that
there was so many options
to get the same thing
That's for free.
That's it?
Right. Because I've, I'm guessing none
of us have ever actually bought a hint.
I DVD or hint.
Okay.
Oh, wow.
Well, I did.
I did.
Oh, okay.
I bought the classic.
I bought mother knows breasts.
Did you actually, I actually bought it.
Yeah. I bought a physical copy
because obviously the podcast.
Yeah. I, it hasn't arrived yet.
I bought it because I was like
I noticed that the, that who's selling it.
They eventually, delist the older ones.
And I thought, well,
I've got to get a copy
of mother's breast just
in case it goes into that.
That doesn't count
because you've already seen him to it.
It's going to be pristine.
You bought that for me.
I bought it to preserve
this is the you're going to frame.
And you're going to begin to
show your kids and be like
kids cost me $50.
Well, that's understandable.
Right? Like, no
one's going to frame
their Brazos subscription
on a wall.
Right. So it's like, when you mean
there are people out there
But because it's like, you know, you hear
about those, you know, that'd
be like politician scandals
and they'd be like, he
spent $40,000 on porn.
I'm like, I don't know.
I even know how you would do that.
Or you start to spend
that much money on porn?
I don't even know how you
go about how would you, like
what I want to know is how would
you not have enough sources
of porn that you need to spend money on?
I think a lot of people want
like specific porn, right?
Like, I think again,
like this is where a lot
of like independent craziest company.
No, no.
That's, that's totally the reason why
only fans this thing, because I feel like
No pay $20 for something I a dude.
Right? Yeah.
I mean, like for me
for me, like, I can't,
I can understand why
people would want to support
independent creators.
Like for example, only fans or something
because you know, you, there
there is that parasocial
relationship in there.
And I can totally understand
why people would want to
spend money on that.
I don't understand like
browser subscriptions
or just like when there is no parasite
there is no parasocial relationship.
I would almost argue that only fans
and all those parasocial
relationships are way worse
off than getting a break.
I totally agree with you.
It is a dangerous
I don't even like dislike
anything about it.
I just feel sad.
But I look at it all.
Like, I just feel sorry for everyone.
Like, I mean, other than the creators
are making bank, right.
Good for them.
Like totally understandable.
The grind you do what
you gotta do, but like
what do you look at some
of these guys and you
see what some of them say online?
Like, you just feel sad for them.
Yeah.
This isn't to demerit any like, Oh
I don't work as, or anything like that.
This is a lot of the,
they make is awesome.
And a lot of them put
a lot of work into it.
Like I just feel dangerous
Line that I don't want to cross.
I don't want to go into that.
Cause if you, if you pay for
One, I feel like you'll do it again.
I'll probably buy another one.
I know some really good ones
and it's dangerous for the
creator as well, because
Then you get, you know, some
of these supporters who get
a little too comfortable
with it and try and start crossing.
Like, I can't imagine
I can't imagine what they
have to deal with on the day.
Huge, huge respect to them every time
Like creepy dude, you
know, thinking that just
because they paid like a
grandiose amount of money
to this creator that suddenly
they're like best friends
you know, when that's
just not how it works.
A few of them on Twitter
this is pretty good to
see like, Oh God cut.
What do you see?
I like just seeing what they get
up to is like it, I mean, it's sad.
Some of the they got to
deal with just to like
you got to like fight just to take
to have people take you serious.
Yeah. Yeah.
Oh my God.
Yeah, because the thing
is, I would like to think
Everyone's end goal for
watching porn is like, you know
an offset for being able to go
into like a happy
relationship where you just
feel satisfied and, and
like happy with banjo life.
So, you know, you stop wanting to be horny
and you just be happy.
Yeah.
Saying Brandon horny happy.
And I feel like if you
go out and pay for porn
you're crossing a dangerous
line where I've no return.
Right. Not, not that you can't
return from it, but you're
you're getting comfort.
It may not be dangerous.
I'm just perceive it to myself.
Yeah. That's I mean that this
is, this is sounds dangerous.
Everyone has
Brian has a different line.
This is my line as well.
Where if I go out and cross this line
it's the line that I'm not comfortable
with myself being about.
And you know, some people are comfortable
and I'm sure there's
healthy people out there who
You know, have I'm sure
The thing was the addiction thing, right?
Like it's like 95, 95% of
people are totally capable
of self-regulating and
not over-consuming things
but there's a good amount
of people out there
where they find that one
thing that just breaks them
and they just can't stop.
Yeah. Like it's just what it is.
Yeah.
And it's just, we go back to the point
of how would you recognize
what, what point is too far?
Is it when your life is
being actively ruined
or when you just can't
find a happy relationship?
Yeah. Which is like, again
why like going back to that
video, like massive props
to the dude for being
able to like stop himself
and be like, you know what?
This is getting out of hand.
Yeah. Yeah.
And honestly, like I, to me
I was just amazed
that he was willing to
talk about that publicly.
And you know, to me, I
was like, that's like
that's like pretty big balls to come
out and be like, listen guys, I'm addicted
to porn knowing that people
are going to meme you.
Yeah.
But in, in reality, yeah.
There's probably a lot of
people going through that.
And I have massive respect
for the guy for coming
out. And I think I remember as
Well, like from what I saw hardly
Any meaning at all, the
comments were really positive.
Again, like w when the stuff is sensitive
people don't want to talk about it.
Cause they mean it.
But it's really important
to have people come
out and be like, listen,
this is a real thing.
I'm like, it's me
over. Yeah.
It's the exact same thing with
for example, Gacha addiction, you know, we
we can meme the out of it.
But if someone has an issue,
you should take it seriously.
And you shouldn't just think
that people are going to mock you
and meme the out of you.
Some people with addiction
to anything is never good.
Some people will
but the good people out there
will actually understand that.
You know, you can have
an embarrassing problem.
Sometimes. Sometimes
it's hard to tell when
you've gone too far
Joey plays era games.
You know, I feel sorry for him.
You know
You play leagues
I cleaned, by the way.
I
Know you it's like duality of man.
Right?
I haven't played a ranked game
on my account and like full
full five months on my
account there I've helped.
Okay. Okay.
Got it.
But I'm clean.
I'll tell you is also clean
all our patrons right here.
There's the amazing segue
in the history of this show.
I, I, I would like to say a shout
out to this particular
patron for being wonderful.
Look at it.
Go. Why this one?
Why? Why?
Because why not?
Why not?
Wow. Flavor G fuel.
You guys drinking.
I'm drinking water.
I finished it because it was so delicious
but I had the pink lemonade.
Oh. Was actually really, really good.
The famous Berry face,
berries, Berry drinking, gone.
I am drinking the Pewdie pie flavor.
You're drinking.
Pewdie pie juice.
Yes. I am jealous.
Well, I hope you guys have enjoyed this.
This is what to go to
the weirdest segments.
Like we just had so many varying topics.
Jesus Christ.
Hey, you guys had fun.
We actually talked about anime
for one like the majority of this podcast.
Sure. Weeks in a row.
Disgusting. I'm not talking
about anime for four months now
But if you guys like
to follow us on Twitter
we also have a sub Reddit
post us your means there.
And also listen to us on Spotify.
If you hate our faces.
Hopefully once this episode aired
we would have reached a
hundred thousand members
in our Reddit, which is crazy.
It would be absolutely awesome.
What are you doing?
Go during the ride or wasting your time.
Do you know how much you
mean potential there?
Wasn't this episode
Alone. I'll review you'll meme.
Eventually
Again. Meme review.
Let's go.
Anyway. I've been giggle with the boys.
This has been trashed tastes
and we'll see you guys
next time.
Bye bye.
So bonus scene there about
show me Minecraft porn, and
obviously we can't show this
on YouTube, but you can show
My reaction.
So I don't know.
Oh, I'm on like x videos.
Oh yeah.
That one.
I think
Minecraft, Porn on YouTube.
Does that, is that really porn?
That's viral.
Yeah. This is the one I sold
that where I was just like
okay, this has gone too far.
All right.
I've got the audio.
Can you hold it so that I can watch it?
I want to see what your watch can
Do. I have to make sure it's like muted.
No, no, we'll be fine.
It's muted.
Don't worry.
It won't come up in the microphone.
. This is the one I saw.
This is the one I saw
What the fuck?`
If I can name MMD right now watching.
Oh, is he going to start?
Oh. Oh.
Is he going again?
Why does it look like that?
Oh, wait, the enemy just came
out with his like
incidentally great animation.
Oh, Oh
Oh. Oh, wait.
Is that a, is that a?
Is that an anal?
Is this anal right now?
Oh my God.
This, this is animated.
I can't, I can't look
away, but that's fine.
Oh, it's like, no, no, this is just good.
This is when.
Oh, it's the stomach.
Bogin everything.
This way.
This went like full on like Corina.
I think I've seen enough.
I've seen enough.
I'd rather watch gang bangs right now.
I mean, you basically just did.
I am just, I, if I walked
into my son watching that,
I would be disappointed.
I'm telling you, I'm
saying the way we just
watched one minute 30 out of
an eight and a half minute.
How many views does I have?
That's on X videos.
600,000 views.
- Nice.